Moin, äh, mein Sound, mit meinem Sound stimmt fast nicht, äh, Michael 5 Spillianen, Dankeschön für den Sub, irgendwas stimmt hier mit dem Sound nicht, wartet mal, wartet mal, hier ist irgendwas, hier ist was richtig kaputt an dem Sound, warte mal, mal lauter, aaaah, jetzt ist ok, alles klar,
ich hab, ich hab aus Versehen mein, äh, mein Audio Interface leiser gemacht, aber, na warte mal noch ein bisschen, so, so ist gut, muss ich mir nicht selbst ins Ohr schreien, ja, da bin ich wieder,
Kruf Electric, 14 Monate, Dankeschön, ok, jetzt wo ich's grad, wo ich grad Electric lese, ich hab, äh, mit einem Elektricker telefoniert, dass ich endlich mein Ladegerät in Hof gebaut bekomme, fürs Elektroauto,
dann hab ich ein Ladegerät, dann hab ich den Home Assistant eingebunden, hoffentlich nach dem Stream heute, und dann ist alles gut, dann kann ich endlich fahren, ne,
wir müssen doch gerade mal schauen, dass Home Assistant geupdatet ist, ja, ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch, wo wir stehen geblieben sind das letzte Mal,
Hallo YouTube, ne, ne, wir kommen nicht, kommen nicht, der Stream kommt nicht auf YouTube, ich lad doch eh keine Streams auf YouTube, höchstens mal ab und zu, irgendwelche Ausschnitte,
wo are you, I am Pog, fange an im Oktober Informatik zu studieren, pauschal irgendwelche Hinweisetipps anreden, keine Ahnung, ich hab nicht Informatik studiert,
da musst du dir mal einen anderen fragen, warum sagst du immer Stream, ich weiß nicht, ich find das irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das sag,
ich find das besser als Stream, ich glaube ich hab mir das bei irgendeinem Streamer abgeguckt, der hat auch Stream gesagt, ich hab bloß keine Ahnung mehr wer das war,
hä, keine Ahnung, ich mach das alles übers Web Interface, bitte prüfen sie ihre E-Mail Adresse,
tja, wir prüfen nicht unsere E-Mail Adresse, oh Leute ihr müsst kurz weg gucken, hast du den MQTT Stick, ein Stick dafür, warum soll ich ein Stick, hä, was soll denn ein MQTT Stick sein,
ja wie gesagt, ich hab grad vorhin mit dem Elektriker telefoniert, demnächst, also nächste Woche kommt er vorbei und guckt sich das an und dann macht das, also ich hab bald auch ein Ladegerät,
so, aber, ich hab mal kurz meinen Home Assistant updaten, was hat er denn für eine IP gekriegt, guck mal das nehm ich doch total, total alt, ich muss das Ding mal updaten, ähm, ne das ist nicht total alt, das ist gerade mal monat alt, eins, drei, zwei,
so, Settings, Updates, Home Assistant Core Install, gib ihm, ähm, also das weiß ich nicht genau was da, was da Sache ist, hä, weil ich klick da immer nur im Web Interface,
ich mach tatsächlich, ich mach tatsächlich auch mal manchmal ein paar Sachen über SSH, aber das ist dann eher, äh, das ist eher selten und das sind dann so Sachen wie, keine Ahnung, Datenbank, immer rüber kopieren lokal, weil ich mit SQLite irgendwas reingucken will oder so, aber, äh, an deinem ThinKline, durch den du Home Assistant install, äh, wie das, äh,
was ist denn eine Mobo Box, du meinst das Gerät wo Home Assistant drauf läuft, das ist ein HP Micro Server Gen 8 Plus oder so, das Teil,
okay, keine Ahnung, wo ich das mal getweetet hab,
wie gesagt, auf einem HP Micro Server, HP Dell, Moment, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, warte mal, ist das Dell oder HP, Micro Server Gen 10 Plus, HP, HP, da drauf, da drauf, da läuft aber noch ein bisschen mehr, da läuft nicht nur Home Assistant drauf, ja, da läuft noch ein bisschen mehr,
aber nichts, was irgendwie super, irgendwie viel Leistung fressen würde oder so, ach so, du meinst, was ich verwende, um ZigBee zu machen, ich mach, also, Wireless Protokolle mach ich in ein paar Sachen, ich hab,
Z-Wave Geräte, ich hab ein paar ZigBee Geräte, ich überleg grad, was hab ich denn für ZigBee Geräte, äh, ein paar Buttons, genau, also ZigBee Geräte hab ich tatsächlich gar nicht, gar nicht so viel, also,
ich hab ein paar Z-Wave Geräte, ich hab ein paar ZigBee Geräte, ich hab ein paar WLAN Geräte und ich hab tatsächlich ein paar Bluetooth Low Energy Geräte,
also ich hab so ziemlich alles an Wireless Gedulds, irgendwie, gefühlt, was man haben kann, hat sich die letzten Jahre überall so angesammelt, Max, Dankeschön für den Sub, Massive Subscription hier, äh, by the way,
ich mach mal hier weiter Update, während ich das beantworte, jaja, install, installier mal, ähm, da hab ich für Z-Wave einen, äh, EOTech Stick oder so,
oder, wie heißt das Ding? Z-Wave A EOTech Stick, so ein Teil, genau, und für ZigBee, und für ZigBee hab ich einen KonBee 2 Stick.
Alles für den Scam Train, ja mal gucken, es ist ja September, da ist es ja billiger.
So, ähm, dann hab ich, lass mal überlegen, jetzt nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie das jetzt Blödsinn erzähl.
Gut, WLAN brauchst du ja nix extra, gehst halt ganz normal übers Netzwerk, die Geräte hängen dann im WLAN, allerdings Netzwerktechnik sind ja normal erreichbar,
und für Bluetooth hab ich tatsächlich gar nix, ach ne, ich hab tatsächlich noch eine andere Geschichte, ähm, also für Bluetooth hab ich tatsächlich gar nix im Home Assistant,
weil ich das Ganze mit ein paar ESP32s mache, und deswegen bin ich äußerst gespannt, was die gemacht haben in den letzten zwei Home Assistant Versionen,
weil ich hab schon zwei, drei Monate nicht mehr geupgraded, ich bin wirklich gespannt drauf, was die Bluetooth technisch gemacht haben,
die letzten paar Home Assistant Versionen, weil mittlerweile muss man keine eigenen Bluetooth ESP's mehr im Haus verteilen, um Low Energy Bluetooth Zeug zu empfangen,
das kann Home Assistant jetzt direkt, und zwar kannst du ESP's flashen und die halt quasi als Bluetooth Proxies verwenden, keine Ahnung,
man muss ja halt keine eigene Firma mehr aus den Fingern saugen für die Dinger, mal gucken, wie das funktioniert, ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert,
zumindest meine Thermostate könnte ich damit auslesen, ich könnte damit die Flora Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor auslesen,
ich könnte die Waage auslesen, inklusive Batteriestand, also da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf, ob das taugt, aktuell keine Ahnung,
weil ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert, ich hab immer paar Tabs offen, so und dann hab ich noch, ja, ja was denn jetzt,
hat er geupdatet, Pog, alles updaten hier, so und dann hab ich tatsächlich noch was vergessen, ich hab noch so ein Oldschool Funkstick dran, 433 Megahertz,
für paar Sachen, beispielsweise für die Rollos und für die Wetterstation, ja das war's, also da ist ziemlich viel Mischmasch dabei,
aber da kommste nicht drum herum, du wirst selten das hinbekommen, dass du quasi eine Funktechnologie hast und dann alle Geräte dafür bekommst,
zum Beispiel finde mal eine gescheite Zigbee-Wetterstation, ich weiß gar nicht, ob sowas sinnvoll gibt, wahrscheinlich gibt sowas gar nicht,
so, genau und außerdem, jetzt kommt demnächst noch Matter und Threat und was es nicht alles gibt, das wird eher noch mehr,
ja, ok, das hab ich jetzt ja beantwortet, dankeschön für den Sub her, ach, ich hab mich schon gesehen, aber trotzdem, Pog, Subscription,
möchtest du mir sagen, dass ich das ausprobieren soll oder ist das Werbung für das eigene GitHub Repo,
in welcher Heizkörper-Thermostate hast du in Verwendung, sind sie empfehlt, also ich hab am Anfang mal Zigbee-Thermostate ausprobiert, allerdings hab ich mir nie da wirklich viele gekauft,
was, gibt's neuerdings irgendwelche Browser-Plugin-Exploits oder was gibt das hier,
also ich hab mal früher Zigbee-Thermostate ausprobiert, die waren aber alle nicht so geil,
ich hab aktuell tatsächlich so die einfachste Variante, die man auch als erstes findet, nämlich,
die sehen anders aus als meine, das da, ach, gibt's da jetzt neue oder was, Alter 96 Euro für ein Thermostat, seid ihr noch irgendwie ganz bei Trost oder was, 96 Euro, Alter was ist denn mit denen los,
Moment Leute, ich guck mal kurz nach, ich mein die Dinger waren vorher schon viel zu teuer, aber 96 Euro,
die Dinger waren vorher schon teuer, aber, ja, aber so teuer, Alter was kann das denn, ist das irgendwie, hat das noch ne Fritzbox integriert oder was, oder sind das 5,
warum kostet das so viel, ok, ok, Moment, also hier ist 59 Euro, warum kostet, was kann das denn tolles, was ist das, was kann das besser,
so kann man das irgendwie vergleichen, Versus 301, ok, wenn die PC Welt das schreibt, dann ist ja alles klar, also,
Epaper Display, bla, bla, bla, Deck, Achja, Deck hab ich auch noch am Start, ähm, bietet offensichtlich alle Funktionen zu 301 und kann wie dieser über Funktaster,
Smartphone, Tablet, ja, ja, bla, ok, aber, hä, die Dinger wirken so ziemlich exakt genauso wie die, ok, die haben die keine Menütaste mehr jetzt,
und man kann anscheinend zwischen heiß und kalt direkt umschalten, ja, ok, ganz ehrlich, ich steuer die Dinger doch eh nicht, man hat doch solche Thermostate,
wo man sie eben nicht von Hand zu steuern, was, was, das verstehe ich, so, ähm, das heißt, die können nichts Neues, oder was, nichts wirklich Sinnvolles Neues,
außer, dass es neue Gehäuse hat, ach, das Epaper Display ist drehbar, ok, das ist tatsächlich ganz nice, weil aktuell guckt man halt Schäpp drauf,
Boostfunktion für schnelles Aufheizen, das müsst ihr mir jetzt mal erklären, wie, wie ich mit einem Thermostate boosten soll,
das funktioniert doch überhaupt nicht, wie soll das funktionieren, wie soll ich boosten damit, ich mein, ich kann den, ich kann diesen, diesen, ähm,
ich kann das Ding, ach, der dreht voll auf, ja, aber das ist doch immer so,
das können doch, das können, äh, sag mal mal so, wenn du so ein 0815 Thermostate hast, ja, und du stellst das auf 22 Grad ein,
dann macht das auf, sodass warmes Wasser in die, in die Heizung kommt, und ob ich jetzt ein normales Thermostate auf 22 Grad oder auf 25 Grad stelle,
das wird auch nicht ständig warm, und ich überlege gerade, warum das anders sein sollte, weil ich mein, wenn es unter der Temperatur ist,
wie es sein soll, dann macht er halt auf, und wenn die Temperatur erreicht ist, dann macht er, oder, ach, das machen die nicht, ok,
was auch immer, also den Unterschied, den check ich jetzt nicht so genau, also brauchen tue ich ihn auf jeden Fall nicht,
ich brauche einen neuen Router, weil mein USG abgeraucht ist und ich von Ubiquiti weg will, ah, das ist schon mal eine gute Idee, entweder nichts lieferbares oder Mondpreise,
nehm doch einen, also je nachdem, was du routen willst, wie sieht es denn mit sowas hier aus, alter, der Scheiß ist auch teuer geworden,
das hat mal vor ein paar Jahren noch 70 Euro oder so gekostet, wie sieht es denn mit sowas in der Richtung aus,
ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie viel ich für die, für die Thermostate bezahlt habe, das interessiert mich jetzt einfach mal, ok,
warte mal, Your Orders, Fritz, ok, ich hab damals bezahlt, zeigt mal her, Order Details, das war im Februar 2001,
als ich die gekauft hab, 46 Euro, Leute, ich hab 46 Euro damals dafür bezahlt und jetzt kostet, was ist denn das hier schon wieder,
46 Euro und jetzt wollen die da für allen Ernstes, ja gut, ist ja nicht mal lieferbar, jetzt wollen sie beim billigsten Anbieter hier schon 59 Euro, na gut,
ja, aber trotzdem, alter, ist schon teuer geworden, gibt es eine Möglichkeit Apple Music in Home Assistant zu integrieren,
keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht ausprobiert, weil ich kein Apple Music hab, ach, gibt's einen neuen,
nee, das ist ein anderer, das ist der mit SFP Plus Port, den braucht doch kein Mensch daheim,
also, ich schon, allerdings ein SFP Plus, aber die meisten brauchen das doch nicht, hab ich 2001, äh, 2021,
wobei ich überleg grad, ich glaub, mein Hex PoE hat auch, hat auch, ähm, ein SFP Plus, stimmt, was ist denn der Unterschied,
oder, ach, das ist ein neuer, oder was, das ist quasi, neue, neue Version da davon, wenn du es so willst,
oder wie ist das, warte mal, müssen wir mal schauen, ach ja, guck mal, der hat jetzt zwei CPUs anstatt von einer,
ja, das ist auch nicht schlecht, kost, ja, das ist, das ist doch mal ne Ansage, 69 Euro,
hä, hä, hä, hätt's ja so gedacht, Kackel, alter, hätt's da so gedacht, vor wegen 69 Euro, na ja, doch,
eine Bewertung, bei denen hab ich mal was bestellt, schon ne Weile her, und es kam an, also, das ist doch okay,
na, das Einzige, wo's lieferbar ist, ist halt, alter, warum ist denn aktuell alles so schlecht zu bekommen,
und, und so teuer, na ja, gut, eigentlich ist klar, woran's liegt, China, auf der einen Seite an den China-Chinesen,
auf der anderen Seite Krieg in der Ukraine, und wahrscheinlich wird alles mehr oder weniger mit diesen zwei Sachen zusammenhängen,
was machen eigentlich die Schiffe vor Shanghai, dürfen die wieder rein, die haben sie nicht mehr alle,
das ist fast genauso schlimm, wie ich wollt, wie gesagt, ich wollt ja einen Elektriker holen,
der mir ein Ladegerät fürs Elektroauto installiert, die hatten alle Wochen und Monate Lieferzeit, alter,
richtig hart, also, so, dann gehen wir jetzt mal kurz in die VM, und fangen mal langsam an,
will er vielleicht mal updaten, anstatt, ah, komm, auch alles updaten, alles drauf hier, gib ihm,
sind alle ausgebucht, das ist echt nicht mehr normal aktuell, das ist wirklich voll, jawoll, wir sind up to date,
das ist wirklich vollkommen verrückt aktuell, du kriegst kaum was, und wenn, ist es mega teuer, habt ihr mal versucht,
oder was heißt versucht, versucht hat es wahrscheinlich keiner, weil es zu teuer ist,
ich hab ja gesagt, ich kümmere mich erst nächstes Jahr um Solaranlage und sowas fürs Dach,
aber das wird überhaupt nicht funktionieren, du kannst aktuell schlicht und ergreifend nichts kaufen,
und das was du kaufen kannst ist ultra teuer, und du findest auch niemand, der dir gerade was installiert,
weil alle sowas haben wollen, na, ich hätte mir das doch vor zwei Jahren angucken sollen, allerdings,
vor zwei Jahren hatte ich noch kein Elektroauto, und dementsprechend habe ich das alles noch ein bisschen
hintergeschoben und gesagt, warum soll ich das machen, so, mal gucken, ob unser Programm vom letzten Mal
noch läuft, oder ob ich mir einen neuen Fake Account machen muss, oh, ah, ich weiß woran es liegt,
ihr müsst kurz weg gucken, chat, Augen zu, Augen zu, ich hab die Secrets schon wieder gelöscht,
ok, alles klar, bin wieder da, gucken, ob mein Fiat Account noch funktioniert,
oder ob die ihn schon wieder gelöscht haben, ne, fuck, die haben meinen Fake Account einfach gelöscht,
was soll das, warum löschen sie, Fiat, wenn ihr meinen Fake Account löscht, dann mach ich mir einfach
einen neuen Fake Account, weil so schwer ist es jetzt auch nicht gewesen, einen Fake Account anzulegen,
aber vielleicht brauchen wir heute gar keinen direkten Zugang zu Fiat, weil wir wollten,
ich wollte mich heute eher um die Home Assistant Integration kümmern, und das ist relativ einfach,
ich hab nämlich zweimal Response mitgeschnitten von meinem Auto, natürlich anonymisiert, Leute,
ich copypaste euch hier nichts mit Fahrzeug ID und hast und haste nicht gesehen alles,
öffentlich auf Twitch, aber ich hab Responses von der API mir mitgeschnitten,
also eigentlich brauchen wir gar keinen Fiat Account, was war denn das hier, ah, irgendwas anderes,
dann kann ich das hier auch zumachen, die Solarzellen kommen aus China, kommen sie,
gebrauchte Solarzellen, weiß ich nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, welches Auto hast du,
ich hab einen, den hier, ja, kein Agila mehr, mittlerweile könnten die aber glaube ich richtig
Kohle machen, naja, das ist glaube ich mittlerweile jedem klar, oder, dass er vielleicht noch in Zahlen
das gleiche Geld hat wie vor einem Jahr oder vor zwei, allerdings, dass er dafür nicht mehr
das gleiche bekommt, ich glaube, das hat mittlerweile so gut wie jeder mitgekriegt,
und wenn nicht, würde ich mich wundern, dann rennen ihm die Angestellten weg,
und dann kann er keine Kohle mehr machen, weil er keine Angestellten hat,
also so einfach ist es ja nicht, ja, da muss die Leute schon ordentlich bezahlen,
sonst macht er auch keine Kohle mehr, wenn die Leute keinen Bock haben, bei ihm zu arbeiten,
da gehen sie halt woanders hin, naja, do it yourself, bin ich mir nicht mal so sicher,
ob ich das so eine gute Idee halte bei Solar Panels, gut, also, dann gucken wir uns das mal an,
ich mach mal hier die ganzen Krempel zu, ich weiß nicht, was ich hier noch alles auf hab,
aber ich mach mal kurz, ich mach mal weg, so, unser Home Assistant ist hier,
das ist die IP von dem Ding, und diesen ganzen Krempel hier können wir zumachen,
die zwei Projekte, wo wir letzte Woche was abgeguckt haben, das lassen wir nochmal auf,
das könnte durchaus sein, dass wir das brauchen, also, Leute, was wir machen ist folgendes,
ich will mein Elektroauto in Home Assistant integrieren, was wir das letzte Mal gemacht haben ist,
ach, deswegen ging das Login nicht, wait a minute, vielleicht ging das Login nicht,
weil ich die Secrets ausgetauscht habe, und es war auch nicht Kekke, sondern, was war die?
Kurz rückgängig machen, hier, da steht doch die E-Mail irgendwo, oder? Ach nee,
das war einfach nur Fake da oben, okay, hat keinen Sinn, ich hab die Daten von da oben sogar nie benutzt,
okay nee, Fiat Login funktioniert nicht, da muss ich mir echt einen neuen Fake Account machen, zumindest ist es auch wurscht,
also, ich hab vor, mein Elektroauto zu integrieren in Home Assistant, die Sache ist die, es gibt für Home Assistant keine Integration für Fiat bzw. Uconnect,
für IO Broker gibt es sowas, gibt es zum Beispiel diesen Adapter hier, man könnte jetzt sich zusätzlich für diese eine Sache einen IO Broker installieren
und die Sachen da irgendwie rüber pumpen, aber das ist mir ehrlich gesagt bisschen zu blöd, leider gibt es keine Screenshots davon,
dass ihr seht, wie es im IO Broker aussieht, doch hier, guckt, da, also da kannst du dann so Sachen auslesen wie Charging Level,
ob es eingestöpselt ist, da kannst du sagen, Klimaanlage an, Klimaanlage aus, Türen auf, Türen zu, Hupen und sowas in der Richtung,
so und so eine Integration bauen wir jetzt für Home Assistant, Login mit Fiat funktioniert, das haben wir das letzte Mal ausprobiert,
deswegen werde ich dieses ganze Ding eins zu eins, so wie es ist, weil das funktioniert ja, werde ich das Ding eins zu eins, wie es ist,
mal in eine eigene Datei packen, dass wir wieder unser Main frei haben, um die Home Assistant Integration zu machen,
so und dieses ganze Fiat Session Info Zeug, das kommt da einfach jetzt auch mit rein und dann ist Ruhe, so
und jetzt können wir uns um die Home Assistant Integration von dem Kram kümmern, also ich zeige euch nochmal die Response,
beziehungsweise die Sachen, die ich mitgeschnitten habe von meinem echten Auto, die wir heute dann mal in Home Assistant pumpen können,
weil ich kann mich ja im Stream schlecht mit meinem Account hier einloggen und
mein Passwort und meine Mail Adresse leaken und ihr schließt dann mein Auto auf, wenn es irgendwo rum steht, Moin Sarix,
also ich weiß nicht, ich will auch 2000 Euro pro Stunde netto haben,
ihr macht das ist, also wenn man ja eins auf Twitch gelernt hat, ist das man dem Twitch Chat mit allem wichtigen immer nur vertrauen kann,
Open Pilot, was ist denn Open Pilot, Open Source Driver Assistant System, Automated Line Center, das hat er bei mir eh schon und Adaptive Cruise Control hat er bei mir auch schon,
brauche ich net, aber ist ne coole Sache, wusste ich gar nicht, dass es das gibt, Pog,
naja, dass das nicht auf Fiat läuft, wundert mich nicht, es unterstützt kaum was die neuen oder generell Fiat nicht,
naja, wenn da Chrysler und Zeug dabei ist, dann könnte auch Fiat dabei sein, ne, aber Honda fehlt beispielsweise, auch doch, der E ist dabei, guck,
war das nicht das Startup von Georg Hotz, anscheinend schon, ich hätte das nicht gewusst, aber der Chat hat sowas geschrieben vor 5 Minuten,
also wird das wahrscheinlich so sein, ok Leute, jetzt muss ich mal in mich gehen, also, wie kriegen wir diesen ganzen Cramp jetzt den Home Assistant,
also wir können uns bei Fiat einloggen und wir können von der Fiat AP Sachen abziehen, ich werde das jetzt mal, also ich habe hier 2 Fake Sachen mitgeschnitten von meinem Auto,
ich zeige euch das jetzt einfach mal hier, mal hier, Jason File, Fake, Response, Jason, ne, Fake, wie nennt man das Ding, ich habe ein 500e, ja, Fake,
Response, also es gibt einmal von der Fiat AP folgende Antwort, wenn man sich alle Autos auflisten lässt, die man hat, das sieht dann so,
der Mockt-Champ, genau, sieht dann so aus, kriegt man diese Antwort, dann sieht man dann z.B. die Autofarbe, das natürlich eindeutig mit dieser Farbe ausgeliefert wurde,
legit Antwort und meine Fahrzeug-ID ist natürlich auch Omega0ID1234789, also da kriegt man so ne Antwort und dann haben wir noch weiteren Mockt-Champ,
dann haben wir noch ne weitere Antwort, die man kriegt, Folierung, ja, das ohne Scheiß, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, ob ich mir das Auto nicht folieren lassen soll,
aber erstens ist das auch nicht ganz billig und zweitens hält das wohl alles auch nicht so wahnsinnig lange, ich habe nämlich ein bisschen im Internet gelesen, weil an sich fand ich die Idee wirklich nice,
Keg W auf die Motorhaube, genau, nee Keg Wade, das Keg Wade hinten drauf, da fährt man einfach überall 30 und hat Keg Wade hinten drauf, oder Porsche-Champ, das Keg-Mobil,
so und dann gibt es noch, also diese Antwort bekommt man von der Fiat API, wenn man sich die Autos für seinen User-Account auflisten lässt,
dann kriegt man ein Array mit Vehicle-Infos, so und, nee mit Vehicles, so und wenn man dann die Details auflistet zu jedem Auto, dann bekommt man eine Antwort mit allen Details zu diesem Auto,
so und ich tue jetzt einfach mal so, als bekomme ich das von der API und wir müssen das irgendwie in Home Assistant packen,
die ganze Autofolieren kostet ca. 2000€, wahrscheinlich sogar teurer aktuell, so, wir machen das ganze nämlich per MQTT Discovery mit Home Assistant,
also sprich, wir gehen nicht über die Home Assistant API oder sonst was, es gibt ein ganz spezielles JSON-Format, wenn man das über MQTT, quasi, published und Home Assistant auch auf diesem Broker lauscht,
dann legt er automatisch alle Einträge an, das ist viel einfacher als über die API zu gehen und finde ich auch schön, ja, entkoppelt, weil du kannst das mit jeder x-beliebigen Programmiersprache machen
und nachdem ich die Sachen ganz gerne in.NET mache, finde ich das ganz gut, dass ich so quasi Home Assistant Integration bauen kann, ohne dass ich echte Python Home Assistant Integrations bauen muss
und man kann es als Docker-Container laufen lassen in Home Assistant, als Addon, das werden wir dann übrigens auch machen, ich weiß nicht, ob in diesem Stream oder im nächsten,
wir bauen dann ein offizielles Home Assistant Addon, also sprich sowas, was man sich hier über den Store installieren kann, allerdings natürlich nicht aus dem offiziellen Store, sondern mach ich halt ein GitHub-Repo, wo das drin ist.
So, darf man fragen, wie viel du bezahlt hast? Ja, kannst du fragen? Ich hab bezahlt 25.200€. Es gibt Leute, die sich das und das auf die Karre packen, ja, warum nicht?
Die können beispielsweise auch noch kein 500e, guck, zeige ich euch. Den 500e unterstützen aktuell eh kaum welche, weil für die ganzen dieser Sachen brauchst du quasi ein Debug, musst du ans Debug-Interface vom Auto.
Ja, heutzutage haben Autos Debug-Interfaces und wo steht denn hier unterstützte Fahrzeuge? Ach doch, die unterstützen den 500e, doch, die können das.
Aber die unterstützen nicht den 500e, sondern direkt über Debug-Interface, sondern über die Web-Schnittstelle. Also das, was wir auch gerade machen.
Bar auf die Gralle oder finanziert? Weder noch bar in virtuellen Zahlen überwiesen. Nee, gibt's nicht.
Ich hab ein Video auf YouTube, wo man ein bisschen was sieht von meinem Home Assistant, aber ich kann meine Home Assistant-Config nicht publishen.
Da ist zu viel Zeug drin, was ich auslagern muss, was ich nicht auf GitHub veröffentlichen will, bzw. Dinge, die halt von Standort bis Auto, Fahrzeug-ID und alle möglichen Sachen gehen.
Das heißt, ich muss das alles in irgendwelche Secrets-Dateien auslagern, gucken, ob es da noch funktioniert, dann könnte ich es pushen. Nee, das wird zu viel Aufwand.
Zumal ich gehe davon aus, dass die meisten Leute mit meiner Home Assistant-Config gar nicht so viel anfangen könnten, weil meine Home Assistant-Config an sich ist gar nicht so groß.
Das meiste ist tatsächlich über Web-Interface konfiguriert. Und die Automations gehen ja auch über Web-Interface mittlerweile.
Also wie gesagt, ich hab mir den ausgemacht, 25.200 Euro, und ich hab's dann überwiesen sofort, das war ja auch ein größerer Akt.
Ich wollte es überweisen und gab das ein, und auf einmal sagt beim Überweisen meine App Fehler. Nur mit dem Unterschied, das dumme ist, ich hab also die Sparkassen-App.
Ich hab die Sparkassen-App auf Englisch, weil mein Handy auf Englisch steht. Und das Ding hat angezeigt Fehler und hat mir dann einmal gesagt, keine Übersetzung für den Fehler.
Das heißt, anstatt mir den Fehler auf Deutsch anzuzeigen, hat es mir eine Fehlermeldung angezeigt auf Englisch, dass es keine Übersetzung für den Fehler hat.
Das heißt, ich wusste dann gar nicht, warum es fehlgeschlagen ist, die Überweisung. Bis ich dann irgendwann mal nachgeguckt hab, hab ich festgestellt, ich hab glaub ich nur 2000 Euro am Tag oder so, oder pro Überweisung-Limit.
Oder irgendwie sowas. So, also Überweisungs-Limit, genau. Und das zweite Problem ist, dass ich es per sofort Überweisung machen wollte, und das geht ja schon mal doppelt nicht.
So, dann hab ich erfahren, man kann in den Settings von der App das Tageslimit auf 20.000 Euro erhöhen. Das bringt mir ja auch nichts, ich muss ja 25.200 Euro überweisen.
Also, und jetzt kommt der Hit. Ich hab dann bei der Sparkasse angerufen und hab gesagt, Leute, ich hab ein neues Auto gekauft, ich wills bezahlen, ich kanns aber nicht überweisen.
Das Limit reicht auch nicht aus, und dann hat die mir erklärt, ich muss jetzt, damit das funktioniert, eine E-Mail schicken, ich hoffe ich krieg das noch richtig zusammen.
Ich muss eine E-Mail schicken an die Sparkasse, wo drinnen steht, bitte für dieses Konto das Limit erhöhen und sofort Überweisung freischalten lassen.
Also, hab ich gemacht. Achso, nee Moment, nicht E-Mail schreiben, das stimmt überhaupt nicht Leute, nicht E-Mail schreiben, falsch, falsch, falsch, das Beste hab ich euch ja gar nicht erzählt.
Nicht E-Mail schreiben, ich sollt es per E-Mail schicken. Also, ich hab mir nen Brief geschrieben, also ich hab mir nen Text geschrieben, ausgedruckt, unterschrieben, abfotografiert und per E-Mail in den Anhang gehängt.
So, dann zur Sparkasse geschickt, dann hat mich eine von der Sparkasse angerufen und hat gemeint, ja wir haben das gekriegt, aber wir wissen noch gar nicht wie ihre Unterschrift aussieht.
Was weiß ich, warum ihr das wissen müsst, nicht wisst, was auch keine Ahnung, hätte mir ja mal einer sagen können. Also, wir wissen noch gar nicht wie ihre Unterschrift aussieht und ob ich nen Ausweis hab, dann sollt ich noch nen Ausweis abfotografieren und dahinschicken, aber mein Ausweis, den ich hier liegen hab, der ist abgelaufen.
Naja, zumindest, dann hab ich den, also man muss sagen, man muss sagen, das ist nicht ein Ausweis, der abgelaufen ist, das ist schon ein vorübergehender Ausweis, weil mein vorhergehender abgelaufen war.
Und der für rübergehende, die halten plus drei Monate und der ist vor einem Monat oder so wieder abgelaufen, ich hab ja immer noch keinen neuen geholt. So, dann hab ich das hingeschickt, fotografiert, dann hab ich noch mal mit der telefoniert und dann hat es zumindest funktioniert.
Dann haben sie das freigeschaltet, dann hab ich sofort Überweisungen gemacht, das Geld war da und ja, paar Tage später hab ich ihn abgeholt. Wie gesagt, 25.200 Euro, weil, also da ist Prämie und so schon alles abgezogen, weil, also normalerweise kostet das mehr, wenn man das komplett neu kauft, bzw. komplett neu bestellt aus Italien, dann ist es eine ganze Ecke teurer.
Ich hatte insofern, dafür war es da auch irgendwie 10 Monate, ich hatte insofern etwas Glück, ich war Probefahren bei dem Auto und in dem Moment, wo ich fertig war Probefahren, meinte der so zu mir, ja, übrigens das hier ist ein Probefahrauto, der ist demnächst auch am Ende hier seiner Zeit bei uns, also wenn ich Interesse hab, hab ich gesagt, ja dann sag doch mal, was ihr dafür haben wollt.
Der hatte irgendwie keine Ahnung, 6000 Kilometer oder so drauf, also es ist nicht wirklich viel gefahren worden und dann hab ich gesagt, ja nehm ich halt das vor für Auto.
Und jetzt steht es bei mir im Hof und ich kann Ports Champen und den Hormuzisten integrieren. Eine Sache hätte ich allerdings gerne gehabt, die hat er leider nicht, nämlich eine Rückfahrkamera.
Noch nicht, nächste Woche wahrscheinlich schon.
Ich hätte gerne eine Rückfahrkamera, die hat er nämlich nicht drin, der hat jede Menge Schnickschnack drin, das vor für Auto, also das was du normalerweise bei der kleinen Ausstattung nicht bekommst, aber eine Rückfahrkamera hat er nicht drin gehabt.
Rückfahrkamera ist nice, weil bei dem Auto siehst du wirklich schlecht durch den Rückspiegel.
Ich hab mal bei Amazon geguckt, es gibt ja welche, die man zusätzlich mit so einem Display ins Auto machen kann und das ist halt die Sache, ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass man diese ohne weiteres nachrüsten kann.
Also auf dem eingebauten Display funktioniert, kannst du eh nur die Original Fiat Kamera und selbst wenn es die zum nachrüsten geben sollte...
Nee komm.
Das ist doch laggy as fuck.
Ist doch laggy as fuck oder?
Zumal ich glaube Carplay kann gar keine Videoanrufe, kann Carplay Videoanrufe wahrscheinlich nicht, Videozeug übertragen die ja nicht.
500E, den neuen, ich glaube der heißt sogar neuer 500E.
3 plus 1 mit kleiner Einladetür hinten, das typische Frauenauto, was der Chat letztens gesagt hat.
Könnte man automatisch machen, per Tasker scripten oder so, aber es wäre auf jeden Fall laggy, das kannst du knicken.
Dashcam Spiegel mit Rückfahrkamera, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, aber die finde ich nicht gut.
Ich hab mir tatsächlich mal bei Amazon, ich zeige euch das mal, Rückfahrspiegel Kamera.
Ich hab mir tatsächlich bei Amazon sowas hier in der Richtung bestellt.
Zum testen.
Ja ich hab mir irgendwie so eins von diesen Teilen hier mal bestellt zum testen.
Also mir hat es nicht gefallen.
Das kannst du anstelle deines Rückspiegels montieren.
Also man kann es auch auf den Rückspiegel draufkleben, äh nicht draufkleben, so dranhängen, aber man kann es auch anstelle des Rückspiegels montieren.
Die haben Mounts für Fiat und so dabei.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist nicht so geil, wie es sich anhört.
Ach 4K, alles Blödsinn.
Was auch immer da 4K drin sein soll.
Das ist nicht so geil, es hört sich cool an, ist es aber nicht.
Wenn du es aushast, spiegelt das Ding zwar, aber bei weitem nicht so gut wie ein Spiegel.
Der Blickwinkel links und rechts ist ganz gut, also besser als mit dem Rückspiegel.
Vor allem durch das Fenster bei diesem kleinen Vier.
Aber nach oben und unten siehst du kaum was.
Also so geil fand ich es nicht.
So geil fand ich es nicht.
Also wenn schon, dann eher was mit extra, mit extra Display.
Und mir wäre es halt am liebsten, ich könnte das nachrüsten lassen.
Das Problem ist aber, wenn du es nachrüsten lässt, ich gehe davon aus, du musst die Original
Fiat Kamera bestellen, wenn überhaupt, wenn das geht und dann musst du es einbauen lassen.
Gut, ich würde es auch selbst einbauen, allerdings, ich glaube nicht, dass es so einfach ist
und im Zweifelsfall kriegst du die also als Normalsterblicher gar nicht.
Also es müsste wenn schon dann die Werkstatt einbauen und ich gehe davon aus, dass es
einfach ultra teuer ist und sich nicht lohnt, wenn es überhaupt geht.
Also insofern halt keine Rückfahrkamera oder ich hole mir wirklich irgendwie so ein anderes
Ding.
Ja oder ich hole mir wirklich irgendwie so ein Display hier oder so.
Wobei, wenn ich so ein Display hole, dann ist es halt wieder um die Frage, wo stellst
es hin, irgendwie sowas hier in der Richtung.
Da ist halt die Frage, wo stellst du es hin?
Weil, ne, wie heißt das, nicht Cockpit, Interior muss man suchen, habe ich gelernt.
Wusste ich auch nicht, dass man das so nennt, aber ihr wisst, ich kenne mich immer nur
temporär dann aus, wenn ich mir irgendwas kaufe und nun hatte ich mir halt mein Auto
gekauft, jetzt weiß ich, dass ich das Interior nenne.
Du hast halt hier keinen Platz, um irgendwie großartig was hinzumachen.
Du könntest, gibt es das vielleicht auch mal als schönes Bild, das man noch sieht?
Ja, das bitte schön als ordentliches, naja, du kannst halt hier nichts gescheit hin machen.
Wo willst du beispielsweise, also mal angenommen, ich würde mir sowas hier als Rückfahrkamera
holen, so ein kleines Display und Kamera, unabhängig davon.
Auf dem Main Display wäre halt schon deutlich geiler, aber gut funktioniert halt nicht.
Wo willst du es hin machen?
Da irgendwie so auf dieses Halbrunde, das hält nicht.
Hier oben drauf ist auch kacke, dann ist es dir quasi im Blick, wenn du aus der Scheibe
guckst.
Hier unten ist dieses Ladezeug fürs Handy, da ist auch nichts.
Ja, ich glaube schon, ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, aber ich glaube schon.
Routen, dann geht das bestimmt.
Leute ihr werdet lachen, ich hab mich schon schlau gemacht, wie man das Auto routen könnte,
bzw. nicht routen, beim Auto nennt sich das ja nicht routen, beim Auto kannst du mit so
einem Debug Adapter, kannst du quasi Änderungen vornehmen, die man normalerweise fiat in der
Werk, oder die Leute in der Werkstatt vornehmen.
Hab ich mich schlau gemacht, aber die meisten Adapter, diese meisten Debug, genau, diese
meisten Debug Adapter, unterstützen den 500e noch nicht richtig.
Und für den 500e brauchst du anscheinend zwei Debug Adapter, einen normalen und einen Highspeed
Debug Adapter.
Frag mir nicht, was die da wieder treiben.
Also, wie gesagt, wo willst du hier das Display hin machen, gibt eigentlich nichts
Gutes.
Gibt doch bestimmt eine Rearcam, die du in CarPlay integrieren kannst.
Ne, gibt es nicht, geht auch nicht, geht auch nicht, weil CarPlay macht kein Video, CarPlay
macht keinerlei Video, Android Auto auch nicht, die machen alle kein Video.
Das einzige was du machen kannst ist, es gibt wohl irgendwie die Möglichkeit, ein geroutetes
Android zu nehmen und das darauf irgendwie frei zu schalten.
Das ist aber ziemliches Gefrickel und ganz im Ernst, das ist wahrscheinlich laggy, laggy
as fuck.
Und gerade wenn du rückwärts fährst, willst du kein Lag haben, auch keine halbe Sekunde.
Also, wenn da einer was cooles kennt, was kein Lag hat, bin ich ganz ohr, aber ich fürchte
nicht, dass, ich fürchte, da gibt es nichts, weil CarPlay ist an sich schon laggy, doch,
aber meiner nicht.
Ich kann fragen, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es geht und wenn es geht, ist
es unsinnig teuer, weil du musst die originale Fiat Cam bestellen und du musst dir das einbauen
lassen.
Da bezahlst du wahrscheinlich 2000 Euro plus nur für das einbauen und bestellen der Kamera
und das sehe ich nicht ein.
So, aber ich bin jetzt fast eine Stunde on, wir haben noch nichts gemacht, wir legen jetzt
mal los.
Also, Home Assistant, für alle, die jetzt dabei kommen, letztes Mal im Stream haben wir
programmiert, dass ich mich bei Fiat einloggen kann und bei Fiat über die AP Sachen abfragen
kann für Autos.
So, ich kann jetzt natürlich nicht wirklich Sachen von meinem Auto abfragen, weil, naja,
ich will keinen Account leaken, mit dem man mein Auto steuern kann im Stream aus Versehen.
Habe ich mir zwei Fiat AP Responses rausgesucht, die so eins zu eins von der Fiat AP kommen,
habe ich vorhin gemacht mit meinem Auto und habe da halt ein paar Sachen wie die Fahrzeug
ID anonymisiert, d.h. wir tun jetzt einfach mal so, als kommen diese Responses von Fiat
und wir versuchen das mal in Home Assistant zu integrieren.
Also, wenn irgendwie einer was cooles kennt, Leute, nochmal zu der anderen Sache, damit
mit einem gerouteten Android irgendeine Kamera über CarPlay reinzukriegen, dann nur her damit,
ja.
Aber wie gesagt, das meiste ist wahrscheinlich laggy und unstable.
Könnt ihr nachher mal danach suchen.
Okay, auch geht's, Mockchamp.
Also, wir tun jetzt mal so, als kommt von diesem Fiat AP Client, den wir hier gebaut haben,
als kommt das aus dem Internet.
Das ist zwar statisch aus Dateien, aber wir tun einfach mal so, als kommt das aus dem
Internet.
Das ist im Prinzip nur eine USB Kamera.
Das läuft flüssig, da kennst du CarPlay und Android Auto aber schlecht.
Das ist aus Prinzip laggy.
Also, allein schon die Übertragung, bis sein CarPlay Zeug auf dem Display drauf ist, dauert
irgendwie gefühlt eine halbe Sekunde.
Also, du willst halt, ganz ehrlich, du willst bei einer Rückfahrkamera auch keine halbe
Sekunde lag haben.
Du willst gar keinen lag haben.
Welches OS?
Cute Ahoy, Pogname hier, ach nicht Cute Ahoy, fast, fast, das ist Manjaro mit i3 WM, wobei
ich von Manjaro weg will, weil Manjaro sagen, die ganzen Linux-Checker soll man nicht mal
verwenden.
Und wenn die das sagen, dann ist das so, wenn Reddit sagt, das darf man nicht verwenden,
dann ist vorbei.
Da sind wir uns hoffentlich einig.
Endeavor OS ist das wahre, ahja, ich werde mein, ich werde ein ganz normales Arch Linux
nehmen.
Haben wir sogar schon installiert hier.
So, also wir tun jetzt mal so, genau, hier ist die Abfrage mit Autos drin, das faken
wir jetzt mal.
Wir machen keine Abfrage von Autos, machen wir nicht, wir laden jetzt die Fake-Responses
aus, dann tun wir so, als kommts aus dem Internet, Pass, File, Open, Read, All Text, war das so?
So, und zwar aus Fake, warum hat eigentlich Rider keine Datei-Completion, haben die bestimmt,
ich weiß bloß nicht, wie man sie aufmacht.
Ja, warte, JetBrains File Completion, das haben die bestimmt, ich weiß bloß nicht,
wo das, wo, wo es das gibt, also, Punkt Jason, wie gesagt, wir tun so, als kommt das aus
dem Internet, ja, das kommt nicht wirklich aus dem Internet, aber eins zu eins so sieht
es aus, also sprich, wenn man dann die, mal seine echten Passwörter eintippt, dann funktioniert
es auch.
So, also, jetzt haben wir die API abgefragt für, wie viele Autos haben wir, das heißt,
ich brauche hier noch eine Response in dieser Form, übrigens, wer keinen Bock hat, wer
keinen Bock hat, Jason Klassen in.NET zu erstellen, kann QuickType nehmen, oder gibt
es zig andere solcher Tools, die erstellen einem aus dem Jason Output eine Klasse, das
ist äußerst, Moment, das ist äußerst, wird angezeigt, wenn es included wird, ah, so was
hier, oder was, sowas hier, dann wird es angezeigt, ah, das ist gut zu wissen, so, also, Vehikel
haben wir hier, so, das Ding heißt Response User ID, ja, meinetwegen, alles gut, so, dann
haben wir noch Details, da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, oh, Leute, ich ahne was Schlimmes,
oh, oh, oh, ich ahne da was ganz was ekliges gleich, wisst ihr was, und zwar, wir müssen
ja dieses Nested, diese Nested Response hier, was heißt eigentlich partial, dass die Klasse
nicht komplett an dieser Stelle steht, sondern dass du die Klasse an mehreren Stellen verteilt
schreiben kannst, ups, oh, also wenn die partial ist, dann muss die nicht nur hier definiert
werden, sondern, äh, kann quasi dann, ist gar nicht wie das, kannst du die hier weitermachen
zum Beispiel, ja, aber das braucht man normalerweise nicht, warum es das gibt, ist ganz einfach
erklärt, Windows Forms, weil der Windows Forms Designer Sachen angelegt hat und du
da drinnen dann rumschreiben konntest später, deswegen hat man das gebraucht, nun ja, aber
Leute, ich ahne, ich ahne Schlimmes, und zwar, guck mal, wir haben hier ein ziemlich Nested
Jason Ding, bis zu, bis zu 5 Ebenen Nested, damit wir das in Home Assistant exportieren
können, müssen wir das irgendwie eindampfen, also sprich, ich kann ja nicht in Home Assistant
Nested Jason exportieren, ich kann Sensoren exportieren mit einem Wert und einem Name,
das heißt, ich muss jetzt irgendwas überlegen, dass ich daraus quasi ein Key mache, also
sprich mal angenommen, ich möchte das hier exportieren, ja, in Home Assistant, dann
müsste ich daraus zum Beispiel machen, Vehicle Info, Underscore, Fuel, Underscore, Distance
to Empty, Underscore, Value und als Wert davon an 220, das schreit nach irgendwelchem
rekursiven Dictionary Merch Zeug, das ist wirklich schon Aluhut Zeug, also da, ohje,
mal gucken, ob das gescheit funktioniert, so, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, ja, also
wir haben unsere Autos, so, For Each, genau, Vehicle Response Get ist, ich muss das nochmal
irgendwie, ähm, wir wollen nicht Jason Pass haben, wir wollen Jason Convert machen, und
zwar Deserialize Object, und zwar Deserialize in Response, ja, jetzt passt es besser, also,
jedes Auto, was wir bei uns in der Garage stehen haben, wollen wir jetzt die Details
zu abrufen, das ist relativ einfach, wir haben hier nur ein Auto in der Garage stehen, so,
das heißt als Response kriegen wir hier ein Vehicle Array oder sowas, irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung, und da machen wir irgendwie nochmal sowas wie Public, dann kommt Nested
Jason rein, Details, so, weil das kann ich nicht, das kann ich nicht gescheit, es bringt
auch nix, wenn ich da irgendeinen Type dafür anlege, weil ich muss da nachher das Dictionary
umstricken, dass ich das exportieren kann, müssen wir mal gucken, bin ich mir noch nicht
ganz sicher, wie wir das am besten machen, eh, wo bin ich, wo sind wir stehen geblieben,
also, Vehicle Details, gleich, kann man eigentlich, ach, Load, man kann direkt eine Datei angeben,
oder was, ne, na, das ist natürlich nett, Pass, oder halt wieder meinetwegen, ganzen
Text, was sagt der mir dann, Use Async Overload, Nope, Vehicle Details Response, so, und wenn
ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht hab, Return, so, dann ist das jetzt hier unsere Fake API,
die wir verwenden können, gucken wir mal, ob das ganze funktioniert, Piat, Client, Patch,
Await, Autos, ok, schauen wir mal, ob da jetzt eine sinnvolle Response rauskommt, Bäm,
alles klar, so, da sind wir, da sind unsere Autos, Distro, das ist Manjaro mit E3 WM,
weiß nicht, ob es für dich interessant ist, die Kanzlei WBS hat gerade ein Video geladen,
aber geht es, dass Hackers die Heizung autofrei schalten haben, wie sonst in einem Auto, Moment,
es gibt Autos mit einer abo-pflichtigen Heizung, wirklich, ja, also mittlerweile ist echt alles
möglich, das heißt, das Auto hat eine Heizung, aber es ist software-mäßig freigeschaltet,
oder nicht freigeschaltet, Heizung as a Service, Heater as a Service, so, Wärme, Wärme as
a Service, ein Abo für die Sitzheizung, wie, Alter, also mittlerweile geht es wirklich durch
mit denen, das ist echt nicht mehr normal, aber in heutigen Zeiten wundert mich nicht,
ich meine, in heutigen Zeiten gibt es Leute, die geben Geld an Sachen wie, da wundert
dich nichts mehr, da haben wirklich Leute mitgemacht und haben gedacht, nein, Bitconnect,
das ist bestimmt kein Scam, der Frazier, ich frag mich, wo er gerade steckt, ich hab schon
eine Weile nichts mehr von ihm gehört, also, meinen gibt es noch, aber ich hab schon eine
Weile nichts mehr von ihm gehört, mit Tattoos beschäftigt, ja gut, das weiß ich, aber was
er genau macht, keine Ahnung, gut, also, wir haben die ganzen Autos von der API bekommen
und jetzt wird es leider etwas kompliziert, ich fürchte, damit wir die Sachen in Home
Assistant exportieren können, also wir werden das Ganze über Integration, über DMQTT, ach,
den Heizungs-Champer haben wir mal exportiert, alles klar, wir werden das Ganze über DMQTT
machen, die Sache ist bloß die, wie ich gerade erklärt hab, ich kann da nicht einfach einen
Jason exportieren, ich kann bloß einen Wert und einen Value pro Sensor exportieren, das
heißt, ich muss mir irgendwas überlegen, wie ich daraus jetzt ein flaches Dictionary
mache, das wird eklig, ich hoffe, das kriege ich heute Abend, ehm, hirntechnisch noch hin,
muss mal kurz Lichtern machen, hier ist übelst dunkel, Decke, jupp, passt, so, also, wie machen
wir sowas, wir haben ein Jason-Object und daraus, was will ich denn daraus überhaupt
machen, also, probieren wir das mal aus, so, und da haben wir jetzt die Details drinnen
zu dem Auto, wo dann sowas drin steht, wie viel Reifen hat das Auto, ja, das steht da
tatsächlich drin, ich gehe davon aus, es ist bei Fiat Hardcoded als 4, aber sicher bin
ich mir da nicht, oder beispielsweise, wie viel ist die Batterie geladen, ist der Luftdruck
in Ordnung und sowas in der Richtung, einfach von Stackoverflow copypasten, das ist eine
gute Idee, jopt, warte mal, C-Sharp, Jason, irgendwie Compact oder sowas, nee, was soll
ich denn da suchen, Jason, wie nennt man sowas, flat, flatten, flatten, Jason, C-Sharp, alles
klar, ja, das klingt schon mal gut, Moment, guck mal hier, der macht auch irgendwelche
Autodinger, was, exellent, sowas da, genau, genau sowas da in der Richtung, siehste, schön
Stackoverflow klauen, das ist immer gut, ich versuche das gerade mal zu verstehen, was
der Typ da treibt, also, Public, Jason Helper, ok, Dictionary String Object, ja ok, das
ist klar, das brauche ich, Deserialize and Flatten, String Jason, achso, das hier ist
das eigentlich interessante, das ist das eigentlich interessante, nee, Leute, komm, wir machen
das selbst, wir machen Sixhead-Time, Leute, Sixheader, Chat, Chat, ich brauche die Energy
von euch, sonst klappt das nicht, müsst ihr mir die Energy giffen, sonst fällt mir dazu
nichts ein, also, lass mal überlegen, wie heißt das Ding hier, flatten, kann ich es
nicht compact nennen oder so, flatten, flatten, Dankeschön, Chat, jetzt geht das, also,
void, nee, Moment, mach ich da, wobei das geht schon, void, ok, lass mal kurz überlegen,
also, nee, nicht void, Dictionary, ReturnType wollen wir in Dictionary haben, String String
soll zurückkommen, weil ich will ja was Exportierbares haben, ja, Giga Head brauchen wir jetzt, Moment,
gibt es, FFZ Giga Head, nicht Giga Chat, gibt es Giga Head, nein, Leute, Chat, ich habe
eine Emote-Lücke entdeckt, 7 TV, den habe ich nicht aktiviert, neue Idee für Chain
Log, das ist doch mal gut, ja, da ist er doch, passt doch, da ist er doch, wie gerufen, Informatik
Leistungskurs 12. Klasse ist nun Visual Basic, ist es wenigstens visualbasic.net oder ist
es noch visualbasic.6, da lernt man ja wirklich was fürs Leben in der Schule wieder, Punkt
net, da immerhin, by the way, Microsoft unterstützt das selber nicht mehr, ja, also, visualbasic.net
bekommt keine Updates, das ist out, End of Life, gibt es da große Unterschiede, keine
Ahnung, ich habe weder VB6 viel gemacht noch VB.net, kann ich nicht sagen, was für ein
Emote Giga Head, ich weiß nicht, wie es aussehen soll, aber mir ist gerade eingefallen, dass
es das anscheinend nicht gibt, also Chat, Moment, 5 Head Time, jetzt überlegen, also,
wir was, flatten, so, als Argumente brauchen wir, als was haben wir das hier, J-Object,
nennen wir das mal, Container, das sind nur noch 15 Namen, das kann alles sein, Container,
also, wir müssen das jetzt rekursiv zusammenpacken, 7 TV App, Giga Head, nee, das ist doof,
das ist blöd, genau, Leute, 5 Head Time, ich mache mir das jetzt einfach auf dem zweiten
Monitor auf, easy, da kann ich sagen, ich gucke nicht ab und alle denken, ich bin mega
6 Head und ich kann im Zweifelsfall doch abgucken, das ist gut, sehr gute Idee, also, ok, wir
müssen auf jeden Fall schon mal alle Objekte durchgehen, das geht nicht anders, Container,
Key Value Pair, oh Gott, rekursives Zeug, Alter, und dann muss ich das quasi wieder
aufrufen, mit eigentlich dem Value, so, aber so einfach ist es natürlich nicht, weil,
ich will ja den Key hinzufügen, also, brauche ich nicht nur den Container, sondern ich
brauche auch einen Key, der Key standardmäßig ist Root, weil mir nichts besseres einfällt
für das erste Element, ach du Scheiße, wie machen wir das jetzt, so, wenn der eine Ebene
tiefer geht, Key, Key plus den neuen Key, ach nein, ich muss es umgehen, also, Moment,
ergibt das irgendwie Sinn, also, der nimmt das Root Element, nimmt davon alle untergeordneten
Elemente, nimmt den aktuellen Key, am Anfang ist es Root, danach ist es das, was ich übergebe,
und hängt da hinten dran den Key an, also sprich, der würde jetzt quasi das hier sich
schnappen, davor Root hängen, und dann eins weiter gehen, oh Scheiße, ob das funktioniert,
Bonkers, Alter, so, das geht nicht, weil, J-Token is not assignable to J, okay, kann
ich das hier J-Token nennen, nein, natürlich nicht, oh Scheiße, muss es rekursiv sein,
okay, muss es nicht, wenn dir was besseres einfällt, hau raus, was für ein Auto wurde,
es ist ein 4 und 500 E, Alter, mir fällt das, ich guck gerade bei Stagoverflow ab auf der
anderen Seite, aber das bringt mir auch nicht wirklich was, wie der das macht, okay, okay
Leute, mal kurz in mich gehen, also J-Token, Stream, damit das funktioniert, muss ich das
Dictionary noch übergeben, Dictionary, das Dictionary muss ich übergeben, immer eine
Ebene weiter unten drunter, weil ansonsten ist es weg, so, und dann muss es optional,
ja, dann ist das hier halt Standard, dann ist das beim ersten Mal Null, und dann gucken
wir, wenn das Dictionary Null ist, dann legen wir Initial 1 an, nee, oder, Change Parameter,
okay, nullable Dictionary, ist in Ordnung, lass ich mir gefallen, mit dem Streamer Money
wäre der AMG drin gewesen, du wirst lachen, ich war mal meiner Friseurin, kurz bevor ich
mir das neue Auto abgeholt hab, und irgendwie hatten wir es davon, und die meinte auch zu
mir, ja, darfst du fragen, was es gekostet hat, hab ich halt auch gesagt, 25.200 Euro,
und da hat sie gemeint, boah, davon kannst du schon AMG fahren, ja, aber ich will eigentlich
kein AMG fahren, aber da sieht man mal den Stellenwert, den du da hast, mit einem Fiat
500e, oh, du hast, Tommy, du hast recht, Fiveheader Time, Massive, das ist, das ist HEMA, Next
Gen Z Sharp, alter, Null Assigning Operator, nee, wie heißt denn das Ding überhaupt, wie
nennt sich das Ding, wie nennt sich das Ding, Moment, der Null Zusammenfügungsoperator,
gibt's das, gibt's das vielleicht auch auf Englisch, ok, Null Coalescing Assignment Operator,
exellent, siehst du, richtige Sixhead Sprache mittlerweile, so, Dictionary, wir müssen das
Dictionary weiter runter geben, nee, Leute, wir müssen das anders machen, wir müssen,
das funktioniert anders, das funktioniert anders, wir müssen IF machen, genau, jetzt,
jetzt, jetzt hab ich ne Idee, jetzt weiß ich, was wir machen müssen, also, Postchamp, Leute,
Postchamp, wir müssen gucken, IF Container ist ein J-Object, wenn das nämlich ein J-Object
ist, dann weiß ich, dass es weitere Unterobjekte hat und ich kann da ne Schleife drüber machen,
so, Value, nee, doch, oder, Value, muss der das nicht so was haben wie Value, Moment,
ja, äh, wie kann ich in Whistle Basing in Weir's Coden, Weir's Coden ganz normal, oder,
einfach so Value, hä, bin ich jetzt bescheuert, das hatten wir doch, ach, nicht, oh, ich vertippe
mich auch die ganze Zeit, ja, Key Value per Value wollen wir haben, weil ich wollt grad
sagen, ich hatte es doch oben stehen und da ging das doch, wenn man das richtige eintritt,
dann funktioniert's, so, okay, das müsste jetzt an der Stelle schon mal funktionieren,
so, und dann müssen wir nämlich oben drüber checken, IF das da ist J-Value, weil dann
haben wir ausgepackt, komplett, dann ist fertig, wenn ich ein Value gefunden habe, dann will
ich Dictionary, Add, Key, und dann, keine Ahnung, Value, Value, so, ach nee, Moment,
ich muss es, ich muss es to String stringen, Value to String, okay, was hat er jetzt verschmerzen?
Possible Null Assignment, hä, nee, kann doch einfach so machen, kann ich nicht, hier nicht,
nee, hier, nee, nee, was stört ihn, was hat er verschmerzen, Possible, nä, das kann ja
tatsächlich Null sein, ach so, weil der hier nicht Null sein darf, oder was, ah, ach so,
Moment, der soll ja auch gar nicht Null sein, der soll Null als String haben, glaub ich
zumindest, ich weiß nicht, wie das realisiert wird, wenn ich ihm sage, das ist okay Null
zu sein, müssen wir mal, müssen wir mal schauen, aber Chain of Whistle Basic ist wirklich ppega
shit, so, nee, wir machen den Else If draus, dann passiert da nichts, so, If Container,
wenn das ein Value ist, dann will ich es entpacken, und ansonsten, okay, mal schauen, was da jetzt
rauskommt, ich bin gespannt, Return Dictionary, ach jetzt gehen wir nicht auf Kicks mit Null
Referenz und sonst was, okay, das kann doch nie Null sein, das kann doch nie Null sein,
eh, oder, wait a minute, ach nee, nee, Moment, mein Return Dictionary, ach jetzt ist er glücklich
oder was, na dann ist alles in Ordnung, okay, also, jetzt probieren wir, da bin ich ja mal
gespannt, ob das was wird, okay, J-Token, Root ist okay, eigentlich brauche ich ja sonst
nichts, guck mal was da rauskommt Leute, war ja klar, dass das wieder richtig gut funktioniert,
wo, 23, ach hier, wenn es kein Value hat, wenn es kein Value hat, kann ich auch nicht
zu String machen, und jetzt, hey, Leute, das sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus, Dump,
das ist eine Extension Method von mir, die es wahrscheinlich so auf GitHub tausendmal
besser und getesteter gibt, das serialisiert einfach das Objekt worauf du das aufrufst
als Jason und macht Console-Write-Line formatiert, das einzige was ein bisschen fancy ist, ich
habe eingebaut, dass du das auch auf Async-Objekte machen kannst, also du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel,
wenn du das hier, mal angenommen, das hier wäre, das hier wäre Async, task, mal angenommen,
das hier wäre Async, dann kannst du trotzdem sagen, kannst du trotzdem sagen Dump, weil
der quasi einmal awaitet, mit diesem, diesen komischen Hack hier habe ich von Stack Overflow,
das hier sieht gar nicht mal so schlecht aus, oder, vielleicht sollte ich dann noch, wartet
mal, wir machen das anders, wir machen da ein Underscore dazwischen, ich glaube, das
ist besser, das kann man so machen, wir machen dann Underscore dazwischen, Alter, ich kann
nicht tippen gerade und guck mal, was da rauskommt, Leute, das sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus,
das ist mehr oder weniger das, was ich haben will, nur mit dem Unterschied, das ist nicht
alles, das ist deutlich zu wenig, was gibt es denn noch für einen Fall, es ist was ein
JSON-Object oder es ist was ein JSON-Value, was kann es denn sonst noch sein, ja natürlich,
es kann doch ein Array sein, das gibt es ja auch noch, ist Underscore Unique, ne, ich
glaube, das passt, guck mal, das kann ja auch ein Array sein, ja, hier, guck zum Beispiel,
guck mal, wo sind denn hier alles Arrays drinnen, schedules, Tire Pressure zum Beispiel, ja,
das ist ein Array, warum ist denn das, achso, weil es mehrere Reifen gibt, also, da muss
man noch Arrays supporten, also, else if, was, if, ich name off, wie kommt er denn jetzt
auf, name off, was, was geht, with fallback-value, wieso, ich kann doch einfach sagen, empty string
ist erlaubt, gut ist, empty string ist erlaubt, alles gut, gucken, ob es dann auch funktioniert,
und wo Null Null steht, dann steht Null da, ist doch gut, ist doch alles gut, also, was
sagt er mir hier, ne, ne, ne, wenn schon dann die Kurzschreibvariante, jetzt müssen wir
noch gucken, ob es ein Array ist, else if, container is json-array, was, manchmal checke
ich, checke ich das Auto komplett nicht, Array, und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich, wenn ich
das so richtig sehe, das gleiche nochmal machen, einfach das Array durchlaufen, mit dem Key,
ach so, ne, das funktioniert ja nicht, Arrays, Array-Elemente haben ein Index und keinen
Key, also kann ich kein for each nehmen, sondern muss eine ganz normale Schleife machen, for
E in Array count, ähm, ups, was, alter, was ist, ich greffe die Tasten nicht mehr, so,
value, ach so, wo kriege ich denn das value jetzt her, äh, var, muss ich, Token, Array,
komm mal Leute, ich kann wirklich nicht mehr tippen, merkt ihr das gerade, wie ich tippe
sonst was auf meiner Tastatur, so, Token, muss man da auch value machen, ne, ne, ne,
ist das selbst, so, und was mache ich denn jetzt als Key für das Array, den Index oder
einfach den Index, wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob Index wirklich, vielleicht sollte
ich sowas hier machen, Array, und dann nochmal underscore Index, ergibt das Sinn, ok, ausführen,
ups, bisschen viel, ja, ey, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz gut aus, guck mal, das ist
doch genau das, was ich haben will, jetzt haben wir dieses, diesen ganzen nested Krempel,
hier raus, so, gut, vehicle info, Tire pressure, Array index 1, pressure value 0, so, ja gut,
ist halt 0, aber, das ist ja das interessante für mich, Status, normal, ja, das scheint
zu funktionieren, die Frage, wie zuverlässig die Sortierung ist, die Sortierung ist doch
egal, in welcher Reihenfolge das ist, Sortierung ist mir egal, musst du nicht einen rekursiven
Call machen im Loop, hab ich doch hier, Home Assistant braucht nicht so ein Kack Format,
du kannst den Home Assistant aber halt nur einen Sensor anlegen und der hat halt einen
Wert, du kannst keinen Sensor und 20 Untersensoren vom Sensor machen und so, also das ist eigentlich
nur notwendig, dass ich ein Unic Name habe für den Sensor und halt ein Value dazu, aber
das ergibt Sinn, doch, das passt, das ist glaube ich alles, was ich brauche hier, das
sieht sehr, sehr nach dem aus, was ich haben will, das ist nice, doch, Funst, ok, dann
können wir uns jetzt, Leute, Leute, jetzt kommt Absolute Next Level Sixhead Shit, passt
mal auf, Dictionary, Public Static, passt mal auf, guckt hier, Excellent, funktioniert,
Extension Methods, genau, so wunderbar, gut, Compact Jason, weiß nicht, wie ich es nennen
soll, gut, jetzt haben wir unsere Kram in einer Format, dass ich Home Assistant irgendwie
unterschieben kann, ok, wie nennt es sich, flattened, wie ist denn die, die, die weiß
gar nicht, wie sich das nennt, flattened, flattened, Jason, schmoll, ich glaube, das
ist besser so, gut, jetzt muss ich den Kram in Home Assistant reinkriegen, flattened,
ja, das kann auch sein, das bleibt jetzt so, was schlägt denn, lass mal kurz gucken,
was schlägt denn Ryder vor, Dictionary, das ist toll, doch nicht mal Ryder weiß, was
ist da wirklich, was ist da wirklich reinschreiben soll, schmoll Jason heißt das jetzt, gut,
weiter im Text, also, jetzt muss ich das irgendwie in Home Assistant packen, also ich hab das
in einem Format, Key ist, wie der Sensor in Home Assistant, es ist natürlich, du hast
recht, es ist ja auch ein Dict, das ist dann quasi, wenn man das bisschen, bisschen falsch
ausspricht, ist, yep, schmoll Dict, aber, ist korrekt, es ist ja auch ein Dict und kein
Jason mehr, so, also der Key ist das, wie das Sensor in Home Assistant heißt und der
String ist der Value für diesen Sensor, gut, jetzt brauch ich eine MQTT Library, Leute,
was ist die beste.NET MQTT Library, ich kenn bloß die da, gibt's da noch mehr, gibt's
bessere, bestmqtt.net Client, wie viel Sterne hat der, ah, das ist schon mal recht verbreitet,
MQTT.NET, M2MQTT.NET Core, Monka, kann irgendjemand den Autor aussprechen, Mohawk, nee, krieg
ich nicht auf die Reihe, so, wo ist der Link, wo ist der Link zum GitHub Repo, was, Moment,
das ist doch, das ist doch das Eclipse Zeug, was auch Moskito hat, ok, das letzte, ok,
die letzten Updates, 8 Jahre, 7 Jahre, 8 Jahre, 3 Jahre, das ist glaube ich nicht das aller
aktivste Projekt hier, nee, es gibt bloß MQTT, ich glaube es gibt bloß wirklich MQTT.NET,
Moment, Moment, es gibt schon eine fertige Home Assistant MQTT Integration, Sekunde,
vielleicht muss ich das gerne selbst machen, MBW Hass MQTT, der ist perfekt, der braucht
keine Updates, ach so, ach so, ach so, ja, dann ist ja alles klar,
das ist auch äußerst vielversprechend für die Library, gibt es doch mal ein paar Examples
oder so, nee, keine Examples, nichts, nee, das kann ich nicht verwenden, was ich über
den Crampel verwendet, ok, nee, wir machen das selbst, ah, wir brauchen MQTT Client,
auf gehts, Managed MQTT Client C-Sharp, Example, jawoll, zeige ich her, das wollen wir haben,
es ist Obvious, wie man das verwendet, genau, das regt mich immer so auf, wenn ich irgendwas
auf Reddit oder auf Hacker News oder so lese und die Leute dann immer so schreiben, Obviously
ist das so und so und bei irgendeinem Thema wo es 5 Leute auf der Welt gibt, die überhaupt
verstehen um was es geht, so nach dem Wort Obviously weiß doch jeder, dass das so ist,
also wir brauchen den MQTT Client, ich Copy Paste mir das jetzt einfach mal, Topic Filter,
Quatsch, Topic, doch wir brauchen einen Topic Filter, ähm, zwar wir brauchen Home Assistant,
ähm, alle, alle Messages die an das Home Assistant Topic gehen, so und das funzt jetzt so, das
muss ich jetzt erstmal ausprobieren, eh, Console Readline, Keck, so, ähm, achso, nee, hier
muss ich ja noch Zeug eintragen, also Client, Fiat, Champ, ähm, mein Broker, Broker ist,
der da, ich mach mal kurz, ich mach mal kurz die Logs, nicht Integrations, mal die Logs
von meinem MQTT Broker auf, um mal zu schauen ob da auch was passiert, IP League, fuck,
jetzt vorbei Leute, F, so, TCP Server, ähm, gibt es sowas wie, Authentifizierung, Mosquito,
Admin 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, Tasmota Offline Online, welches Tasmota geht schickt denn da noch
Sachen hin, ah, die gute alte Hammer Steckdose, ah, dann, ok, bleiben wir mal hier Subs, Subscribed,
ähm, gucken was da so reinkommt, also, ich geh mal davon aus, wenn ich das jetzt ausführe,
dann sagt der mir, ich darf mich nicht connecten, Moment, ich kann mich connecten dazu, Sekunde,
kann ich mich da anonym anmelden, Await, MQTT Client, NQ Async, Alter, warum nennt man das
nicht Publish, überall auf der Welt heißt es Publish, aber nein, hier ist es NQ Async,
kann man bei MQTT per Prime suppen, ja, du kannst probieren, wenn du mich per Prime suppst,
ob du dann dort auch über mich per Prime suppen kannst, xFatal, Dankeschön für den Sub,
38 Monate, Massive Subs, ich leite deine Subscription weiter, aber wie funktioniert das jetzt hier,
Topic, Topic, Kekkel, Message, Lulve, beste, weiß man schon mal Bescheid, so, jetzt sollte
da drüben eigentlich was ankommen, kommt aber nix an, so, und wie krieg ich jetzt raus,
ob ich einen Authentifizierungsfehler hab oder so, oder nicht, woher weiß ich jetzt,
aber ich krieg noch nicht mal hier nen Login, ja, wenn ich mich hier versuche anzumelden,
Sekunde, Leute, wenn ich mich hier versuche anzumelden mit den falschen Credentials, dann
steht nix im Log drin, ok, warum steht denn da nix im Log drin, sollte da nicht was im
Log drinne stehen, nee, das ist eigentlich der Log, das ist eigentlich das Log vom Container,
da sollte eigentlich nix drin sein, aber man kann vielleicht, wo ist denn die offizielle
Seite, vielleicht kann man, muss man Logs irgendwie einschalten, weil Authentifizierungsfehler,
Aero oder so hätt ich mir schon erwartet, dass das, ja, Logins require, gibt's ne, bisschen
ordentliche Beschreibung, ja, nicht verkehrt, ja, super, Home Assistant Logs, Logging, ok,
nein, ja, Log Level, ja, das ist schön und gut, aber hier gibt's ja keine Beschreibung
zu diesem Addon, wie man da irgendwelche Log Levels umstellt, wobei das ein offizielles
Addon ist, ist ziemlich ppeger, ihr hattet agiles Arbeiten in der Schule, nice, ok, ich
geb noch mal ein Port an, man weiß ja nie, vielleicht muss man noch ein Port angeben,
oh, ich mein Default Port hätt ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass das checkt, aber gut, agiles
Arbeiten, was hat man euch da so beigebracht, also ohne drei Daily Stand Ups, Sprints und
Daily Scrums und Scrum Master und ITIL und Save und T-Shaped Teams und so geht da ja
natürlich nix, kann man, irgendwo müssen noch was, müssen noch was in den Logs drinne
stehen, Settings, gibt's vielleicht hier was, System, Logs, Moskito Broker, guck mal, das
ist genau das gleiche, ok, dann weiß ich nicht wie man das Log Level hinstellt, Moskito Addon
Home Assistant Log Level, das muss man doch hoch, Debug True in den Moskito Settings,
warum steht denn das nicht auf der offiziellen Seite, das ist doch schon wieder kacke, das
wäre doch nicht schlecht, gibt's hier was von Debug, nö, gibt's nicht, also hier Debug
True, Save, Restart Addon, wow, das sieht schon besser aus, Checking
Auth Cache Form, ja, jetzt sieht man auch was, gibt es vielleicht ein bisschen weniger Debug
Ausgabe, gibt es sowas wie Debug Info oder so, nicht vielleicht die volle Ladung, das
steht auch nirgendwo oder, ja gut, aber damit kann ich leben, besser zu viel Debug als zu
wenig Debug, im Documentation Tab steht das mit drinne, achso, Alter, ich hab bei den
auf der GitHub Seite geguckt, ok, man kann, aber kann man Log Level, if set to True turns
Debug on, ok, nee, da müssen wir es so machen, alles klar, so, dann passt das, dann gucken
wir mal was er jetzt hier sagt, wenn ich das ausführe, warum er nicht will, vielleicht
wollte er jetzt, ja,.net Run, eh, Sub, MQTT, sollte er nicht eigentlich was schicken jetzt?
Achso, ach, ich däpp, ich schick das ja auf den falschen Topic, Lul, kein Wunder, dass
ich da was sehe, nee, ich bin richtig, ich sollte eigentlich was sehen da jetzt, warum
sehe ich in meinem Broker nix? Sending Publish, nee, Tasmota Discovery, ist wieder was anderes,
sag mal, warum schickt denn der nix? Der versucht sich auch gar nicht anzum, was ist denn das?
Funktioniert das MQTT Zeugnet oder? Ich mein, wie wäre es mal mit einer sinnvollen Ausgabe,
da ob es funktioniert oder nicht? Also da kommt nix, nix an. So, ich bin hier unten,
subscribe zu allem, ich mein, der sollte doch zumindest sagen, dass er sich nicht einloggen
kann, oder? Der versucht sich gerade anonym anzumelden, das klappt nicht. Na gut, dann
machen wir mal, with authentication oder sowas. MQTT, 1, 2, nee, wat? Bytes? Bytes? Wie soll
ich mein Passwort in Bytes angeben? Moment. Nee, das ist für einen Server? UTF-8-Encode,
aber das kann doch nicht denen ernst sein, warum machst du nicht einfach nen String overload?
Example User Passwort. Ja, genau. Wo gibt der denn die Username? Moment, das ist ein Server,
der macht nen Server, ich will nen Client haben. Client-Certifikat? Alter, man muss
doch irgendwie sich da mit Passwortern anmelden können. MonkaS. Managed MQTT Client. User
Passwort. Retry. Ich will nicht retryen, ich will mich per Passwort anmelden. Aha. Okay,
wo gibt er das Passwort an? With Credentials, nicht mit Authentification. Ach, TLS? Nee,
TLS will ich doch überhaupt nicht. Ich will ohne TLS. TLS ist bloated. Nee, das ist unverschlüsselt
das Ding bei mir. So, also with credentials und das gibt's? Ja, okay, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6. So, jetzt sollte es aber funktionieren. Please, pray, aha, alles klar. Okay, größere
Aktion rauszubekommen, wie es funktioniert. Aber es klappt. Gut, so, next. Next. Jetzt
müssen wir versuchen, unseren Campbell zu exportieren. Also wir subscriben, wobei wir
müssen noch gar nicht subscriben, wir wollen ja erstmal nur Sensoren exportieren. So,
also hier haben wir unser Dictionary und jetzt wollen wir den ganzen Campbell an Home Assistant
exportieren. So, das heißt, for each, schmaldigt, Sensor, Values oder sowas. So, und das wollen
wir jetzt exportieren. Da muss ich mir das Format angucken, wie man Home Assistant MQTT
Discovery macht. Das war nicht schwierig, vielleicht haben wir es sogar noch in der
History irgendwie. Mosquito Papp. Heizung, Konfig, das sieht gut aus. Guck dir mal, Heizung.
Mist, wir haben es nur gelöscht. Aber wenn ich sowas hier schonmal gemacht habe, dann
haben wir das garantiert in irgendeinem Projekt drinne, was haben wir denn sonst so zu bieten?
Der Heiz-Champ. Leute, der Heiz-Champ macht MQTT, garantiert. Neues Window. Der Heiz-Champ,
guck mal da. Das sieht gut aus. MQTT Klein Papp. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was wir da gemacht
haben, aber. State Topic, Konfig Topic. Was zum Teufel? Das blick ich doch jetzt nicht
mehr, was ich da gemacht habe. Also, State und Konfig Topic, das braucht man. Okay,
wir gucken uns Home Assistant, MQTT, Jason, Example. Da gibt es garantiert was für MQTT
Power. State Topic. Gibt es da irgendwo ein Example? Irgendwas? Ja, hier, ne, ne. Heiz.
MQTT, okay, Home Assistant, MQTT, Discovery, Jason. Auto Discovery and Jason Payload. Genau,
wie sieht der Krempel aus? Jaja, genau, sowas hier. Ja, ja, genau, das brauche ich. C-Docs,
ich habe in Docs nichts gefunden. Aber wir wollen MQTT Discovery machen für einen Sensor.
Und jetzt ist da ein ordentliches Example drinne. Auch tatsächlich, ne. Es ist nicht.
Kein gescheiter Sachen drin, wie man das macht. Okay, Discovery Messages, das weiß ich. Discovery
Payload. Dokumentation haben sie, ach hier, hier steht was drinne. Das habe ich gesucht.
Okay, Home Assistant, Binary, Sensor, Garten, Konf. Ja, das suche ich, genau. Das, das suche
ich. Das, das will ich, das will ich haben. Okay, also Sensor Data. Das heißt, wir sagen
jetzt MQTT Client, NQAsync. So, Topic. Also wir brauchen ein, das können wir da alles
noch in der eigenen Klasse machen. Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Wir brauchen ein State
Topic und wir brauchen, ups, und wir brauchen ein Config Topic. Da kann ich mir noch dunkel
dran erinnern und das stand da eben auch. So, das Config Topic ist das da. Das ist quasi,
wo, wohin man seine Werte initial schickt. Also wo man sagt, dass es diesen Sensor gibt.
So, wir wollen nicht Binary Sensor, wir wollen einfach nur Sensor. Moin, hier riet es. So,
und das Ding soll dann heißen, wie, wie heißt die, das ist Rider, JetBrains Rider. Okay,
Home Assistant Sensor, das soll nicht Garten heißen, sondern soll heißen. Okay, wir brauchen
eine, wir brauchen eine Unique ID. Und unsere ID ist quasi von Sensor Data, der Name, also
der Name ist das da. Zack. So, hoch scrollen. Das da, das ist der Name. Ne, ne, Max Fake.
Und dann brauchen wir noch das, falls man mehrere Fahrzeuge hat vom gleichen Typ, was
ich nicht habe, aber kann ja sein. Noch dazu die Fahrzeug ID. Fahrzeug ID zusammen mit
dem Key aus dem Sensor, das sollte Unix sein. ID. So, ups. State Topic. State Topic ist
das gleiche mit State hinten dran. Aha, so. Und jetzt können wir diesen Krampel an Home
Assistant schicken. Das da. Nur, dass ich noch irgendwie das Gerät dabei definieren
muss, das ist neu. Also, das haben die hier glaube ich nicht drinne stehen, aber, also
früher konnte man nur einzelne Sensoren an Home Assistant schicken, mittlerweile kann
man komplette Geräte schicken, also man kann quasi sagen, dieser Sensor gehört zu diesem
Gerät. Ich weiß nicht, ob die da für Device, ob die da für irgendein Exempel haben. Mal
kurz schauen. Ne, haben sie nicht. Da müssen wir noch mal danach suchen. Home Assistant,
Security Discovery, Device. Ich weiß noch, da konnte man solche Sachen mitschicken, wie
Manufakturer und sowas. Vielleicht soll ich mal danach suchen. Ach, hier guck mal. Manufakturer.
Der MF. So, der Manufakturer. Hier hat er, ja, das brauche ich. Genau, so was. So was
hier. Genau das. So. Exzellent. So, jetzt haben wir zwei Beispiele zusammengesucht
und können daraus ein Best-of bauen. Wobei, ne. Leute, wir kopieren uns einfach, der Typ
hat ja alles drinstehen, was man braucht. Ey, meine Konsole war gerade einfach weg. Einfach
kurz gedacht. Nope. Ich verschwinde jetzt. Okay, also wir wollen das Ganze an das Config
Topic schicken. So viel, so viel weiß ich schon mal. Und jetzt müssen wir dieses JSON
zusammenbauen. Wir können jetzt ein neues C-Sharp 11 Feature verwenden, Leute. Weiß
ich gar nicht, ob ich das eingeschaltet habe. 11, C-Sharp 11 wollen wir haben. Weil C-Sharp
11 hat jetzt endlich sowas hier, guckt mal. Man kann jetzt endlich sowas machen. Und da
drinne kann man dann beliebig viele, wie man lustig ist, Quotes und Sachen verwenden und
das interessiert die nicht. Man kann es sogar escapen noch. Also wir können jetzt besser
JSON Sachen zusammenbauen. Was müssen wir, also wir müssen sowas jetzt mit unseren Werten
hier zusammenbauen. Also sprich, wir fangen erstmal schon mal an. Klammer auf, Klammer
zu. Klammer auf, Klammer zu. Name. So, das ist jetzt das Device, wenn ich das richtig
sehe. Nee. Device steht immer unter Device da. Also Device. Boah, ob das jetzt hinhaut.
So, Device, Doppelpunkt. Nochmal Klammer auf. Und da merkt sich sogar die Eindrückungstiefe.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht. So, Identifiers. Identifiers klingt eher nach einem Array,
oder? Identifiers, Lul. Das muss irgendwas Unic-mäßiges sein für das Device. Also
quasi die Fahrzeugnummer oder so. Aber wir gehen jetzt einfach mal testweise was ein und
gucken, ob es dann im Web-Interface auftaucht. So, Identifiers Name. Pog Car. Moin. So, Manufacturer,
das brauchen wir eigentlich nicht. Das reicht doch eigentlich. So, Device. So, das soll
Klammer machen. So, Name. Name ist in dem Fall dann quasi, ja keine Ahnung, Sensor-Data.
Ich mach das mal nicht in der Schleife. Ich mach mal einmal testweise sowas hier. Ah nee,
ich brauch das Config-Topic. Na, mal schauen, was dabei rauskommt jetzt. So, Name. State-Topic.
Brauchen wir? State. Wisst ihr was? Nee, Sensor muss das sein. Ich trag da jetzt irgendwelchen
Müll ein. Hauptsache es klappt einmal und dann kann ich es ja befüllen mit dem was
ich brauch. So, Command-Topic, Availability-Topic brauchen wir eher nicht. Unic-ID, das klingt
wichtig. Das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich. Icon. Ja, ganz wichtig. Das Icon brauchen
wir. Nee, ich weiß nicht mal was ich da für einen Icon angeben soll. So, was ist jetzt?
State-Topic. Unic-ID, Name, State-Topic. Ich vermute mal das war's. Bei Identifiers
und Name fehlen... Achja, hast recht. Korrekt. So, mal schauen. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das klappt. Also wir sollten jetzt ein Pock-Car gleich hier haben. Im Home-Assistant.
Schauen wir mal. Hoffentlich hat es funktioniert. Okay, er hat Sachen bekommen. Settings. Integrations.
Aber wir haben es, die weiß nicht. Na geil. So, wir brauchen noch mehr Beispiele. Ich
könnte wetten Identifiers ist ein Array. Ich sag euch, Identifiers ist ein Array. Heißt
du nicht einfach umsonst Identifiers? So, und jetzt? Ach fuck, funktioniert nicht.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Der schickt das überhaupt nicht raus, guck mal. Der schickt
es nicht raus. Seht ihr, kommt nicht an. Kann es sein, dass sich das Programm beendet,
bevor er das rausgeschickt hat? Ich meine, normalerweise würde ich sagen, wenn ihr so
lang ist, Awaiter ist gut, aber man weiß ja nie. Tatsächlich, das hat sich beendet, bevor
es rauskommt. Und haben wir jetzt noch ein Device? Ach shit, nee, aber nicht. Okay,
vielleicht können wir jetzt in die Logs gucken, was schief gelaufen ist. Logs, die sind hier
irgendwo. Logs. Unable to pass. Omega Lul ID 12345678. Wie jetzt? Unable to pass. Wie
kann man Omega Lul ID nicht passen können? Unable to pass. Äh, okay, ich hab Jason ein
Error drin. Ah, da fehlt ein Komma. Das hat auch glaube ich jemand geschrieben im Chat
eben gerade. Ja, komm mal da fehlt ein Komma. Lul. Und jetzt? Immer noch nicht. Immer noch
nicht. So. Was hat er jetzt? Unable to pass. Ah, trailing, trailing, Komma. Davon bestimmt
auch nicht haben. Wisst ihr was? Ich copy paste mir das Ding mal kurz und lass es mal
Jason Jason validaten irgendwo. Ja, du hast vielleicht, wir probieren es mal aus, vielleicht
geht es jetzt einfach auch so. Nope. Scheiße man. Warum ist das immer so ein Crap? Refresh.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt muss ich das mal Jason Jason Formatter, wenn der Chat das sagt, dann
verwende ich das. Invalid. Aha. Error. Ah, ich hab das Öffnende, die öffnen Klammer
vergessen. Valid. Ja, was denn jetzt? Valid. Okay, er sagt, es ist valid, aber er kann es
ergeblich nicht passen. Warum nicht? Komma hinter Pokka. Nee, das darf, darf kein Komma
hin. Okay, also Unable to pass. Warum? Klären. Da ist eins. Ach, da ist eins. Warum ist denn
da eins? Das sollte kein sein. Okay, nochmal. Moment, der hat es doch gefressen. Ja, das
ist doch hier. Zwei Devices. Pokka. Da sind wir doch. Mit einem Sensor drauf. Nice. Delete.
Yes. Back. Funktioniert. Pokka ist da. Okay, nice. Jetzt, okay, jetzt wissen wir schon,
wann das funktioniert. Jetzt müssen wir da die richtigen, die richtigen Sensoren einsetzen.
Also, so, wir wollen das eskapen und zwar mit zweimal, mit zweimal Ausrufezeichen, weil
in.NET machst du String Interpolation mit geschweiften Klammern auf und mit dem Anzahl
der Dollarzeichen am Anfang sagst du, wie viele Klammern in Folge du zum eskapen brauchst
und nachdem in JSON ganz oft Klammern verwendet wird, brauchen wir doppelt Klammer zum eskapen.
In der Hoffnung Rider unterstützt das richtig. Also, wir brauchen jetzt das State Topic.
Das State Topic ist jetzt State Topic. So. Nice. Das funktioniert erstaunlich gut. So,
Name ist nicht Pokka, sondern Name ist vom Device, also spricht das Auto, ist Vehicle
Nickname oder Pokka. Unique ID. Ist die ID von oben?
Hier mal ein bisschen Leerzeichen drum. So, das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich passen.
So, also wenn das jetzt funktioniert, bekomme ich alle meine Sensoren in Home Assistant
rein. Dann schauen wir doch mal. Pokka. Unnamed Device. Was? Nein. Das ist definitiv falsch.
What the fuck? Achso. Moment, ich hab das ja auch so, ich hab das ja auch noch nicht
umbenannt. Ich deb. Da freut sich Gaben persönlich, ja. Aber eigentlich sollte hier der Name angezeigt
werden. Ok, ich glaube wir machen es mal anders. Car Name gleich Vehicle Nickname oder Pokka.
Wobei, komm. Nee, müsste. String. Oops. String Null. White Space, man weiß ja nie,
was da drin steht. Dann ist es Pokka oder es ist das da. Car Name. So und hier kommt
nicht Valve, Valve 1 rein, sondern hier kommt jetzt der Name von dem Key rein, also spricht
das gleiche wie Sensor Data Key Muster rein. Dann schauen wir mal. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob das da auftaucht. Pokka ist schon mal da. Und da ist das Zeug. Also noch keine Werte
angelegt, aber kommt mal hier Tire Pressure. Gut, da müssen wir natürlich noch die Werte
reinkriegen. So einfach funktioniert das natürlich nicht. Wieder löschen. Aber, aber schon mal
alle Sensoren da. Das ist doch schon mal gut. So und jetzt müssen wir Werte setzen. Das
macht man wie? Es stand doch hier irgendwo. MQTT war minus M war das habe ich. Genau hier
minus M. On. Wie einfach On. Na On ist ein ziemlich dover Wert für einen Sensor oder
kann ich da? Nee, ich kann da wahrscheinlich einfach Text. Das muss wahrscheinlich nicht
mal Jason formatet sein. Einfach einfach Text reinhauen. MQTT Client. NQ Async. So und jetzt
das State Topic. Und dann ja an der Stelle halt. Okay, Await. Und an der Stelle jetzt
halt den Sensor Wert. Der Sensor Wert ist ja das, was in Value steht. Also Sensor Data
Value kann auch null sein. Okay, ausführen. Das geht jetzt aber schnell. Pochka. Oh. Unknown.
Leute, ich sage euch, was passiert. Ich werde mit euch. Das läuft asynchron, obwohl ich
es erwarte und hier lege ich den Sensor an und hier setze ich den Wert für den Sensor,
was nicht funktioniert, weil der Sensor zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich den Wert reinschreiben
will, wahrscheinlich noch nicht angelegt ist. Es geht einfach. Ich sende das glaube ich
einfach zu schnell. Gibt es denn die Möglichkeit einen Sensor mit einem Default Wert? Ja, du
hast recht. Sowas wie Flash oder so bräuchten wir. Genau. Also Force Send sowas. Gibt es
aber nicht. Ich mein. Das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren. Aber schön ist es nicht, oder?
Wir warten mal. Wir warten mal 200 Millisekunden. Ich hätte eine andere Idee. Kann man Initial
Value setzen? Hier. Man kann auch bestimmt ein Default Wert für einen Sensor angeben.
Man kann auch bestimmt ein Default Wert angeben.
Expire Force Update. Das Icon. Object ID. Payload Available. Hat einer von euch eine
Buchempfehlung für Software Architektur? Nee. Da kenne ich keine Buchempfehlung. Was willst
du denn wissen? Generell sowas, was allgemein ist oder geht es dir um irgendwelche speziellen
Programmiersprachen und Framework zum Beispiel? Wie strukturiere ich mein Projekt in XY? Oder
willst du generell so irgendwie ein Buch über Solid oder sowas haben? Man kann keine Default
Wert vergeben. Kann das sein? Home Assistant Sensor Default Value. MQTT Sensor Home Assistant.
Default. Nee, man kann kein Default Value setzen. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof,
aber gut. Aber ok, wenn man kein Default Value setzen kann, dann warten wir einfach 200 Millisekunden
und freuen uns, dass es dann wahrscheinlich funktioniert. Jetzt ist es natürlich auch
gleich viel langsamer. Genau, da warte nur, dass es enqueued ist und flasht das nicht.
Das könnte man aber in parallel machen jetzt. Aha, guck mal, und schon haben wir Werte.
Also, Root Info, EV Info, Battery Distance to Empty, 320 Kilometer. Easy. Guck mal, haben
wir die ganzen Werte schon drin stehen, die man brauchen hier. Alter, wie viel Zeug da
drin ist. 23 Kilometer, Batterie, Battery State of Charge, 98 Prozent. Gibt es sowas
wie Plugged In oder sowas? Plugged In Status, True. Ok. Charge Level 2, Charging, hier guck
mal. Charging Status, Charging. Der Rückgabe, ich glaube, das hat gar keinen Return. Nö,
da gibt es keinen Return. Warum chargst du den auf 100 Prozent? Warum nicht? Unter der
Haube chargst du doch eh nur bis 85 oder so. Die Zielsetzung ist erst mal, dass Givert
in den Home Assistant rein kriegt. Dass ich dann zum Beispiel sehe, ja, natürlich, die
meisten Ladesteuerungen machen das ja so. Also, was sage ich jetzt? Halt mal so. Ich
weiß es nicht, ob das so ist. Wäre ich jetzt mal ausgegangen.
Also, das mit dem Warten finde ich tatsächlich doof. Gibt es sowas wie, kann man die Queue
Size sehen oder so? Ne, ich fürchte, wir müssen mal kurz in den Source Code gucken
von diesem Ding, was der da eigentlich macht. Enqueue Async. Ok, bla, Application Message,
Enqueue Async. Was? Ah, Interface Crap, Alter. Enqueue. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich dachte, gibt es doch. Es gibt Pending Application Messages, ok. Vielleicht kann
man ja darauf warten, bis es keine mehr Pending gibt. Habe ich große Kleinschreibung an? Tatsächlich,
Alter. Ok, bla, Enqueue Async. Managed Application Message, Message Queue. Tja, ist die Frage,
ob ich irgendwie auslesen kann, was die für eine Message Queue hat. Ok, also, was gibt
es Pending, Pending Messages? Pending Messages Count. Ok, dann testen wir mal schnell, was,
ob denn der Pending Message Count bei sowas dann größer, größer Null ist. Oh. Da stauen
sich ein bisschen die Messages, würde ich sagen. Ich sende die Messages deutlich schneller
als, dass die, dass die rausgehen. Ja, wie soll ich das jetzt sinnvoll machen? Jetzt
mal, seriously. Wisst ihr was? Ich zeige euch, wir machen jetzt den Trick 17 besser
aller Zeiten. Und zwar, wir sagen jetzt Parallel, for each. Oh, wie, das verwende ich so selten.
Ne, ich mache doch keinen Sleep mit dem Corn. Ich mache einfach 190 mal ein Thread auf und
schicke das. Der Weightet doch eh zum größten Teil. For each, wie geht das Ganze nochmal?
Small Dict, Sensor Data. So, so war das doch. Oh my god. Boom. Async. Mach doch ein Thread
Pool auf. Ne, warum? Das kann doch in den Default Thread Pool, was es in dem Fall ja
macht. Parallel, for each. So, pass mal auf. Jetzt, jetzt schämmerts. Pock, K, löschen.
Pass mal auf, jetzt geht das viel schneller. Guck mal hier. Bam. Oh. Es scheint zu funktionieren.
Die Reihenfolge stimmt jetzt halt nicht, aber das ist ja für mich wurscht. Das scheint
zu funktionieren. Das ist gut. Nice. Weil da ist die Reihenfolge halt nicht immer die
gleiche. Funktioniert. Wir machen jetzt quasi für jeden Wert, den setzen wir parallel ab,
aber beim Befüllen des Werts warten wir 200 Millisekunden bei jedem Wert. Naja, ich meine,
die Lösung könnte tatsächlich schöner sein, aber nun ja, was willst du machen? Es funzt
auf jeden. Oh, Identifier 0 0 0 ist übrigens falsch. Der Identifier muss eindeutig meine
Fahrzeug ID sein. Wege, Fahrzeug ID. Sonst wird das nix. Sonst ist beim zweiten Auto
Schluss. Das wäre ja nicht auszudenken. Da kann ich nix liegen, das ist Fake Daten dafür.
So, und jetzt exportiert er den Kram. Ich würde sagen, das passt soweit eigentlich.
So, lass mal, lass mal raus, lass mal so mal uploaden. Pock, K ist am Start. Ja, wunderbar.
Pock, K ist befüllt. Okay, und jetzt könnten wir beispielsweise ein Dashboard anlegen.
Nur mal so, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Man könnte zum Beispiel Dashboard anlegen. Icon,
K. So ein Auto von der Seite als Dashboard. K. Ja, das ist gut. Save. So, und da fügen
wir jetzt Zeug hinzu. Zum Beispiel Entities. Was? Ja, man könnte das Elektroauto nennen.
Ach, gibt es ein Icon für Elektroauto? Ach, aber das ist von vorne. Das ist blöd.
Nee, nee, nee, ich will das von der Seite haben. So, Add Card, Entities. Erstmal alles
löschen, was da drin ist. Brauchen wir alles nicht. So, Entities. Dann nennen wir so was
zum Beispiel Reichweite. Fangen wir mal an mit der Reichweite. Irgendwas mit Distance
müsste das sein. Battery Distance to Empty 320, sehr gut. Name, Reichweite. So, was
brauchen wir denn noch schönes? Battery. Irgendwie Prozent oder so. Charging Level.
War das State of Charge? State of Charge? Ach doch, State of Charge, 98. Also, was nennen
wir das wie? Ladung. Muss ja auch wissen, was es ist. Übrigens, die Einheiten, ja,
das könnte man alles schön exportieren, wenn man wüsste, wie der Kram vorher heißt.
Also, du kannst, du kannst über MQTT auch sagen, dass es die passenden Einheiten hat,
aber das weißt du ja vorher nicht. Also, was in der Output drin steht. Hier, wenn ich
das Interface mappe, dann weiß ich's. Ach so, Icon sollte man vielleicht auch noch, ich
speichere das erste Mal den ganzen Campbell. Das Icon sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal
ordentlich machen. Icon für Reichweite. Charge oder so. Reichweite, was machen wir da? Flash.
So was da. Weiß nicht. Rocket. Das ist eine gute Idee, das finde ich cool. Die Rakete
ist für die Reichweite, das finde ich, das finde ich nice. Ein eigenes Dashboard für
den nächsten Werkstatttermin. Stimmt, das müssen wir auch noch rein machen. Nächste
Werkstatt, wann das vorgeschlagen wird. So, Ladung, da machen wir jetzt irgendwie Charge
oder Battery. Battery Charge. So was hier, machen wir da, komm. So was. Ladung in Prozent,
ok. So, was brauchen wir als nächstes? Irgendwie Charge Status oder so. Wie war denn das, ob
es eingesteckt war oder nicht? Plug, irgendwas mit Plug. Plugin Status, true. Ja, also, Ladekabel
eingesteckt. Da fällt mir jetzt wirklich nichts gescheites ein, wie ich das kurz in einem
Wort schreiben soll. So, Icon. Irgendwas mit Stecker. Nice. Stecker Status. Ne. Ich bleib
bei Ladekabel eingesteckt. So, was haben wir als nächstes noch? Charge? Es gab doch
sowas, wo noch da steht, ob er gerade Charged oder nicht. Wo dann quasi Charging Not Charging
da stand. Was war das dann? Es war nicht State of Charge. Plugin Status. Charging Status.
Charging. Das da. Ok, das heißt dann dementsprechend Lade Status oder so. Kickt als Icon. Ich hab
sowas wie eine Ladestation als Charge. Jetzt sehe ich so eine Art Ladestation. Oder Stecker?
Meine Stecker wäre dafür eigentlich besser. Blitz. Aber MDI Icons. Wir gucken mal kurz,
was es da so alles gibt. Charging. Oh, diese Seite ist immer so wahnsinnig schnell.
Hopp. Ne. Was nehmen wir denn da? Tanksoil? Ach guck mal, da! Das will ich gar nicht
aufgefallen. EV Station. Ok, das hätte ich im Leben nicht gefunden. EV Station. Was
nicht alles gibt. Ok, nice. Next. So, ähm. Jetzt machen wir Kilometer bis zur Wartung.
Maintenance. Irgendwas. Nee. Factory? Wie heißt der Campbell? Wir können mal ins Jason
reingucken. Patrick, Dankeschön für den Zap. Distance to. Neuer Auto ist Pog. Und wenn
ich das im Home Assistant hab, ist es noch, noch proggischer. Distance to. Distance to
Service. Service. Distance to Service. Warum hab ich das zweimal drin? Distance to Service.
Ach Value. Ok, ich hab das Richtige. 5000. Ja, ich geb zu, ein Fakewert. Service. Äh,
Wrench. Ach guck mal, es gibt sogar fürs Auto ein richtiges Icon. Kilometer bis Wartung.
So. Next. Dann, wenn wir schon dabei sind, machen wir noch den Kilometerzähler. Odo-
Odometer. Jetzt mal, ernsthaft Leute, wusste irgendjemand, dass das Kilometerzähler auf
Englisch heißt? Bis jetzt. Odo- Odometer. Hab ich noch nie gehört vorher. Das wird Counter?
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz gut. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Ähm, na gut, was gibt's
immer bei Battery noch? Time to Charge Total Range. Battery Voltage Value. Interessiert
mich das? Interessiert mich die Batteriespannung aus irgendeinem Grund? Eigentlich nett, oder?
Battery Spannung. Egal. Ach, was such ich denn da jetzt für nem Icon? Verbrauch ist
interessant, ja. Ne, nicht Current. Ich muss Things suchen nach, ähm, äh, oder so. Batterie
bis voll geladen? Ja, natürlich. Batterie bis voll geladen. Das ist tatsächlich ganz
interessant. Natürlich, äh, Battery Charging. Das gibt es, das gibt es. Das hab ich gesehen,
aber ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt. Guck mal, EV-Info war das, glaub ich. Time to Fully
Charge L2. Time to Fully Charge L2. So. L2 ist, dass du mit 230 Volt lädst. Das ist
so Elektro-Auto-Fachsprache. Warum es so kompliziert sein muss, weiß ich auch nicht. Äh, nennen
wir es mal Minuten bis 100%. Das ist doof, dass es in Minuten kommt. Das müsste ich irgendwie
im Home-System umrechnen. Battery. Gibt so was? Battery mit nem Charging-Symbol dabei.
Äh, sowas hier. Das ist doch gut. Okay, nice. Save. Done. Yep, Clock. Das finde ich schon
mal, das finde ich schon mal, das hat was. So, und jetzt können wir, jetzt können wir
noch was machen. Haben wir noch den Reifendruck anzeigen lassen, falls es da nen Fehler gibt.
Grid. Da bin ich mir noch nicht sicher, wie ich das, wie ich das hübsch, wie ich das
hübsch mache. Warum hast du denn schon 35.000 Kilometer? Hab ich nicht. Das ist fake.
Tire. Tire-Pressure-Value. Show-Stay. Null.
Warum ist, nee das brauch ich nicht. Ich brauch Pressure-Warning-Falls. Oder nee, wie hieß
das andere? Für die Reifen-Status. Okay. Tire-St. Nee. Wie heißt der Klampe? Tire-Pressure-Value.
Pressure-Array. Null. Status. Normal. Meine Güte, die Benamungen sind auch schon ziemlich,
ziemlich pepega. Reifen. Vorne links. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob null vorne links ist.
Ich schreib das jetzt einfach rein, weil ich keinen Bock hab nachzugucken. Toggle gibt's
nicht. Keine Action. Hast du eine spezielle, ich hab ein paar Steckdosen, die den Stromverbrauch
messen, ja. Aber Gesamthausstromverbrauch hab ich nicht richtig. Ich hab versucht mein
Zähler mal auszulesen mit so einem optischen Sensor, aber das ist alles nicht so, nicht
so toll. Next. Zack. Next. Zack. Next. Zack. So, das ist nicht Reifen. Das ist vorne rechts.
Das ist Reifen. Hinten links. Ich weiß übrigens nicht, ob man das so abkürzt. Hinten rechts.
Exzellent. So. Tire. Tatsächlich gibt's sogar Bilder für Reifen. Oh. Oh nein. Ah. Mein
Browser ist gecrashed. Ich war zu schnell. Leute. No. Grad noch mal knapp gewesen. Das
hätt ich jetzt noch mal machen müssen. Dann. So, jetzt haben wir den Reifendrucker am Start.
EM24. Ja, aber ich hab so einen alten Ferrari-Zähler an meinem Haus unten. Den kannst du nicht
elektronisch gescheit auslesen. Den kannst du theoretisch nur optisch auslesen. Das ist
irgendwie so ein Pain's Jam Prozess. So, und eine Idee hab ich noch, was man machen könnte.
Wir könnten beispielsweise mal so ne History Card oder wie das Ding heißt, nehmen. Es gab
doch so ne History Card. Nicht Craft History. Es gab so ne History Card im Home Assistant,
der. Ach nee. Ha. Das hab ich bei meinem anderen Home Assistant, aber hier gibt's das ja gar
nicht. Das ist irgendeine Custom Sache, die ich da installiert hab. Weil man könnte beispielsweise
auch noch. Warum hab ich das übrigens als Button gemacht? Richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich wollte noch Trip Distance. Dann hätte man nämlich ne History von den Fahrten, die
man gemacht hat. Aber da brauch ich so ne History Craft, dass es gescheit aussieht.
Wo ist das nämlich? Das ist nämlich ziemlicher Müll. U, mit was hast du das aus? ULS. Ja,
das ist so ne Kamera, die man draufklebt wahrscheinlich. Ja, genau. Sowas hab ich auch schon mal selbst
gebaut. Das ist so ein Infrarotsensor, aber das. Ja, das funktioniert, aber irgendwie
ist das alles nicht so, dass das wahre. Alter, gehste mal weg. Ich will da rein klicken.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt bisschen doof, weil. Kilometer. Weil ich hab keine History
gescheit. Das hätt ich nur, wenn ich einen gescheiten. Mal einen gescheiten, ähm ne
gescheite Graphkarten hätte. Der letzte Fahrt war 45 Kilometer. Ja, super. Viel interessanter
wärs, wenn man die letzten sieben Fahrten sehen würde. Was ja geht. Na, dann liest
die Fahrten jetzt ja aus. Also ich hab die ja in der History drinstehen, aber eben so
kann ich sie nicht anzeigen lassen. Ja, das ist natürlich extrem Sixhead. Der hat, der
hat seine Grafana, der hat sein Tesla im Grafana drin. Na, sowas werde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht haben. Ich wahrscheinlich die ganzen Daten gibt's ja da auch gar nicht. Ich mein,
das ist natürlich schon extremer Sixhead Modus dann. Elevation krieg ich. Na doch, sag
man mal so. Das krieg ich alles raus bei mir. Das krieg ich alles raus bei mir. Temperature
krieg ich glaube raus. Energy used krieg ich glaube ich irgendwie raus. Das krieg ich,
das würde ich alles an Werten irgendwie rauskriegen. Ja hab ich, hab ich schon. Das sind jetzt
zwar Fake Werte, aber die Responses, aus denen wir die ausgelesen haben, sind von der
echten Fiat AP. Aber das reicht doch. Guck mal, hier hast du doch eigentlich alles was
dich interessiert. Es interessiert, ob er gerade am Laden ist. Es interessiert, wie
voll er ist. Es interessiert, was weiß ich, wie lange er noch fahren kann oder so. Ja,
das finde ich äußerst pock. Ich glaube das kann man so lassen. Das nächste Mal, ok,
nächsten Stream machen wir folgendes. Aktuell können wir ja nur Werte reinschreiben, aber
mit Werte reinschreiben ist es ja nicht getan. Wir müssen nicht nur Werte reinschreiben,
wir müssen ja auch Werte setzen können. Nämlich zum Beispiel, ob man die Klimaanlage anmachen
will oder nicht. Du kannst, ach nee. Man kann die Klimaanlage glaube ich nur einschalten
nicht ausschalten. Guck mal, man kann nur sagen Precondition Klima und dann macht das
halt auf das was da eingestellt ist. Du kannst das irgendwie nicht mehr ausschalten. Das
ist ziemlich der Pepega Move von Fiat, oder? Doch, doch, ich kann die letzten Fahrten als
Crit machen. Das müsste man aber mit irgendeiner Custom Card machen. Geht das automatisch aus,
das geht aus nachdem es erreicht ist, glaube ich. Das ist aber halt ziemlich doof. Aber
vielleicht kann man das anderweitig mit irgendeinem anderen Befehl ausschalten. Oder wir gucken
einfach mal in die Fiat App rein und laden uns den apk von der Fiat App runter. Rauhe
ich mich auf die Seite? Ich will keine Dicks und sonst was angezeigt bekommen. Download
das APK. Excellent. Die App ist kostenlos. So, zeig mal her. Wisst ihr was ich jetzt
mache? Ich entpacke einfach mal das APK jetzt und guck mal rein ob ich da irgendwas drin
finde was irgendwie so heißt. Fiat APK. Ist das überhaupt die aktuellste Version die
ich da hab? Oder weiß ich denn was die aktuellste Version ist? Vom 28.7. oder 7.8. sogar. Das
dürfte die aktuellste sein. So, und soweit ich weiß sind APKs einfache Zips. Easy. Entzippt
haben wir das APK. Wenn die Sachen natürlich, also Leute ich spekuliere ja drauf das ist
eine Javascript Anwendung und man kann im Klartext in den Sourcecode reingucken. Oh
es ist irgendwie ein Kotlin Zeug anscheinend doch nicht. Kotlin? Für Android? Achso Java
ja klar. Ich war grad bei iOS. Kackel. Also logisch natürlich für Android. Firebase
verwenden so ok. Ja. Ok. Dann ist mit Sourcecode angucken natürlich nix. Hey was ist das?
Was ist das? Was ist das? Precont. Remote climate. Guck mal. Es gibt tatsächlich Precondition
on und Precondition off. Ja das ist natürlich nice. Die Sache ist jetzt plus die. Also
die Fiat App selber kann das nicht. Die kann nur einschalten. Das hab ich ausprobiert.
Was passiert wenn ich diesen Befehl an mein Auto schicke und der das nicht unterstützt?
Was passiert? Na gut ich schicke das ja nicht direkt an mein Auto. Ich schicke das ja über
die Fiat App. Die Fiat App wird es ja hoffentlich irgendwie cleanen wenn es nicht unterstützt
wird von meinem Auto. Hoffe ich. Naja gut man. Was man kann das sogar decompilen? Relativ
einfach. Darf man das eigentlich? Also darf ich sowas im Stream zeigen wie man APKs decompiled?
Keine Ahnung ob man das streng genommen darf. Nein. Ich denke auch nicht dass man das zeigen
darf. Dann lass ich das mal bleiben. Ich mein den APK runterladen und anzippen dürfte
ich dann schon ok sein. Aber das andere lassen wir bleiben. Auto ist gejailpranked. Ja gut
ich mein hey das ist doch schon mal was hier. Haben wir schon mal die ganzen Sachen im Home
Assistant drin. APKs decompilen also die APKs decompilen ist ein bescheuerter Ausdruck
eigentlich. Musst du ein APK anpacken und dann kannst du die Sachen die drin sind decompilen.
So und decompilen ist wahrscheinlich vermute ich jetzt mal warum weder Twitch das gerne
hat noch ich weiß nicht ob man das überhaupt ja ob man es darf. Gut normalerweise kriegt
es ja auch keiner mit. Ist wahrscheinlich weil man damit irgendwelche wobei eigentlich
wahrscheinlich ist es nicht verboten das zu machen aber wahrscheinlich ist es verboten
das zu zeigen weil es wahrscheinlich in Richtung Hacking Tools geht oder sowas. Ja das hier
ist scheiße da blickst du in Deutschland nicht durch. Bevor ich dann noch Zeug mache was
nicht erlaubt ist. Was ist noch decompilen? Naja wenn du die Binaries in diesem APK nimmst
und sie wieder versuchst in Source Code umzuwandeln der so ungefähr aussieht wie das was man ursprünglich
bei Fiat geschrieben wurde. Es ist nicht wirklich der gleiche Source Code weil es fehlen alle
Kommentare es fehlen meistens die Funktionsnamen also es hat eigentlich nichts wirklich mit
dem zu tun aber die Logik her ist ungefähr die gleiche. So da würde ich sagen das reicht
für heute. Leute wir sehen uns. Ich hau ab. Mal dann im nächsten Stream weiter. Mal gucken
ob die Klimaanlage an und ausschaltbar ist. Bis dann machts gut CU.